genius brain listeners this podcast is
sponsored by better help my friends you
should focus on your mental health this
year every year and for the rest of your
life because it's just better for you
it's better for me I have been using
better help for quite a while now which
is why they are a long time sponsor and
I personally love it I have a therapist
in my back pocket at the comfort of my
home uh whenever I want and because I
have a tough schedule I need a therapist
to be flexible so guess what better help
it's entirely online it's designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule all you have to do is fill out
a brief questionnaire to get matched
with a license therapist at switch
therapist anytime for no additional
charge let therapy be your map with
Better Health visit betterhealth.com
genius today to get 10 off your first
month that's better help
help.com genius
and then I was on TV hold on a second
the sequence when you went to So You
Think You Can Dance that's pretty much
when they were like oh you're really you
were really taking that seriously
because they would see like they would
see like little tidbits of me like it's
I can't hide it all the time but then
that was when they were like possible
yeah why is he grabbing the fort like
potatoes what was that five four three
two one what's up everybody welcome to
another episode of The Genius brain
podcast uh I am your host David so and
we have a very very special guest we
have the train track villain himself
yeah dude thanks for having me man I'll
tell you this man
you coming into JK news has changed so
much since the last time like I was a
regular cast member right and obviously
uh there was a lot of drama in between
everything you know obviously there was
like a really dark time of JK news and
then you guys came in right when
everything was crumbling
I didn't even know that at all if I had
known I wouldn't have came in
everything looked great to me on the
outside this is all [__] all [__]
fantastic
JK news has been around almost as long
as I have been doing YouTube jeez yeah
it has been around forever man yeah so
when when I started
um
I first met Bart and Joe at a San Diego
Comic-Con Comic Con so San Diego nerds
yeah hey guys yes
I met them at a San Diego Film Festival
okay and we kind of like instantly
clicked because we're all we're like the
trashiest people at this yeah yeah yeah
all these other YouTubers like Joseph
Vincent super oh handsome very well put
together Perfect Image great eyebrows
exactly I have this I show up in
basketball shorts slides and socks
basically how I am now nothing has
changed and we're doing these panels and
then Bart and Joe there's these [__]
Dickie jumpsuits so we all look like
pieces of [__] Blue Collar work exactly
you want to hear the funniest part that
I found out after Bart told me that yeah
when he left and he went to go talk to
Geo because Geo was managing managing
them at the time she was like hey when
you go to these events you guys can't
wear just basketball shorts and t-shirts
but I was there just like that because I
didn't give a [__] yeah and so they're
like well he did it he pointed to you
and so I'm like well you guys dressed
pretty casually too they'll know like
the Dickie jumpsuits was us dressing up
I was like wait they thought that was
like they thought that was dressing it's
just casual that's why we [__]
connected we were just like the biggest
pieces of [__] and so like just kidding
news became an onset of what we did at
the time because we you know we've seen
us like you know it's the Asian people
just kicking it in a parking lot exactly
yeah exactly so we're you know I forgot
I think it was Bart or maybe it was Joe
but one of them was like we should just
record this and then see what happens
and then it just became this this crazy
thing and it just blew up from there but
we were the first people like the very
first week of you guys doing JK news who
was that so there was this guy there was
Tommy there was this guy Kevin these are
all people who aren't a part of uh JK
anymore they all moved on to bigger
better things
um Tommy there was the two ands there
were these sisters um uh older Ann and
little Ann is what I call them with the
right very sweet yeah we still like chat
every now and then so cool
um there was Tommy there was Kevin as
well uh Geo me Bart and yeah Joe I'm not
sure if Tiff was in there it was Casey
was in there as well right because I
think at that time
um Tiff was working as I think as a
phlebotomist in the hospital or
something like that and she wasn't a
part of JK at the time oh right she had
like an actual job she had an actual job
she hated that job and then she wanted
to kind of find something else and
that's when Bart and Joe were like hey
like we'll find you some work here and
we'll make it happen so the rest is
history yeah yeah yeah yeah so
um the JK actually started it was so
weird watching that little thing grow we
didn't know what the [__] it was going
to be because we all had our own
personal channels right right so they
had Just Kidding Films where they were
doing sketches every week and then just
kidding news was a side piece with a
side piece damn that's crazy to think
that's the side piece yeah it was the
side piece and then JK news blew up past
all of our [__] yeah yeah and so you
know we did it for quite a while and
then I decided to leave because I wanted
to do other things right so I wanted to
go try acting and that's when I got did
the Sundance thing yeah the Netflix show
I did all this other stuff right
um but it was such a trip and then you
guys came in um during a time where I
feel like
in all honesty if we're gonna just be
honest like JK and you started becoming
the shittiest [__] thing ever
to do or to like watch not to do oh it
was the it was the hardest thing to do
because
to watch because the fan base at the
time there's ones that stayed and
there's a lot of new fans now yeah yeah
yeah but the ones that were there at the
time were a bunch of [__] made [__]
yeah because what happened was that Bart
and Joe had to create a company
and hire people and keep them around
right so it wasn't just I want to do
what I wanted I got to make this company
as successful as possible so people
could have food on their [__] table
Yeah so they became
um bosses right so I think for them like
their mission shifted it's the same
thing what happens with like Kevin Hart
it's like when the same department does
creative and HR it would just make no
sense it was so [__] hard so now
they're thinking like okay we can't say
things or do some certain things because
if we do this and we get canceled we
can't pay uh Casey we can't pay uh Tiff
Tommy kept these people won't have a
[__] paycheck you know I mean Ryan
all these other people so they started
shifting their culture towards like not
saying certain things so that's a real
thing you guys actually because I hear
little bits about that but I didn't know
that it was a thing you guys actively
said we have to be cleaner yeah and I
that's the hardest thing from I can't do
it it's [__] impossible and you
cannot tell me that I can't say
something because it hurts the tip of
your dick and your [__] shut up did they
ever have to stop you like this episode
yeah I was so problematic because I'd
say like
like say whatever the [__] I want and I
would do that on my channel anyways but
then if I'm working with the company
uh-huh I had to play by the rules right
yeah and it wasn't like oh I hate this
it was just more like [__] like things
have changed right yeah and so in order
for me to say what I want and joke what
I want I had to go back to my channel
and at that time I let my channel just
go to [__] oh really you just like kind
of left it
like I was still creating content but it
wasn't my main focus because I was
having so much fun with my friends here
yeah yeah I mean so you're gonna stick
with the thing that has the most fun
right well because you know you start
kind of bending towards too much wokisms
and [__] that's the type of um
fan base that you create so this new fan
base that came from the middle yeah you
forgot that we are garbage like we're
garbage human beings that we are comics
and [__] [__] first right so then
all whenever an [__] thing slips out
they're like shocked and they're like
how could David say that how could they
Dave is this and that Bart and Joe are
[__] [__] like they they never
let let's say okay this is a bad place
for me to be because a lot of those fans
that aren't around for us anymore they
started seeping over into my channel and
that's when I was like okay I have to
make a choice here right like I want to
do my own things I I have to keep this
safe space for myself yeah and if it's
bleeding over then I have to focus on
what I'm doing because I'm too
comfortable here what year was that that
you made that conscious decision that
you couldn't
I forget I have a video where I talked
about me leaving JK and it was just
simply because I wanted to do other
things and it was I didn't even know
that you had left JK yeah I was like a
set Caster the person that allowed was
Steve because every time I would leave I
would leave a hole in JK yeah because
I'm you know obviously I'm very [__]
vocal right yeah yeah and yeah it makes
a nine day difference when you're there
not yeah so it was weird like I would
get texts from like Tiff that's like hey
were you coming back like we kind of
need you back and I'm like oh okay well
and you know it's a lot of I want to say
pressure but then I would feel terrible
because I'm off doing film stuff so you
kind of had like a soft leave huh like
you were soft leave and then you know I
just talked to Bart Jones like hey guys
I think I'm gonna start doing my own
thing and I'm gonna stop doing JK here
and at that time they already brought
Steven so I felt comfortable leaving
because Steve could do this yeah yeah
yeah yeah right so he was he was the
replacement for me and it worked out
really well because Steve [__] kills
it he kills yeah he's like the pro
comedian he's quick yeah right so you
know at the time too like if you don't
know this like Joe mentioned Barton Joe
mentioned this too I think or it was a
Joe that he didn't know what his voice
was because they used to always play
characters
you're saying your opinions you are you
you're not a character so I think that
for them in the beginning of JK was a
little difficult so they needed somebody
to be there to kind of like spark off a
conversation and then they're at it
right they're good to go yeah yeah but
at first like Joe mentioned too that it
was a little difficult and he said it
online too where
um using his own voice was very odd to
hear I I agree because I always thought
he was anytime I'd ever talked to him
was on JK or around JK and then one day
we went to get dinner and he was just
like hey so how you doing and I was like
who the [__] is this I know don't you
mean how you doing like why are you
talking so low are we supposed to keep a
secret where the [__] is the racist
accent I'm gonna beat your ass right it
is that is very true how did you get on
to like JK news I so I I mean I think
the first time I ever came on as just as
a guest was like 2013 or something mad
early and you were there both times I
came on
um 2013 and 2015 and um
and then uh I just remembered like the
last time I went on there I was like
damn that was really fun I want to come
back but I don't want to be awkward and
ask to come back hey
um I'm here
I'm not doing anything ever just sit
down awkwardly yeah I would always have
fun but then I would just wait for them
to tell me like whenever they need
somebody yeah and that would just be
like years in between I'd be like damn
this shit's like really fun I like
building this like relationship with
them and then never seeing them for
years yeah and then uh and then oddly
that one day they were just like hey we
we need someone to fill a seat so then I
went just as panel and not as guest and
then they just said they needed a host
and I ended up doing that it was very
just like as things became available I
just got pulled in and it was a lot of
fun and I said what was the thing that
made you like JK news so much I because
I used to watch it on time it was the
first thing that I ever watched yeah
it's the first thing you ever watched
daily like uh back when you guys started
I was like dude I never thought there
was a thing that I would watch every
morning while I got ready and it was it
was JK news and I'd never seen anything
like it which is kind of I think to me
like it's such a pioneering Endeavor
that to be asked to be part of it like I
always have respect for it you know
that's why I try to not change it as
much yeah I mean like JK news is such a
like even Comics who would come on
they're like dude this is crazy like you
guys literally say whatever yeah you
know the the the the liberating thing
about being on social media and not
having a want to go into traditional
Hollywood is the fact that nobody
controls you yeah the moment you try to
gear your career to going into Hollywood
which all of us did and have stepped in
that realm right is that suddenly your
voice gets this small yeah because you
can't say this because if you do this
person will give you a job if you say
that you offend this person you you
won't be able to do this yeah and you
know being a part of something like JK
news it's like listen you're either a
part of this or go [__] yourself right
yeah either you love us and we love you
back and if you don't want to be a part
of this that's okay too you're a loser
no but it's like we're not for everybody
right yeah yeah and I think when
sometimes when people come on the JK
news they find that very liberating
either they get scared shitless because
they're like we shouldn't I don't want
to put that in or if they come here and
they're like dude I've been wanting to
say this for the longest time and I
never had a platform where I could meet
other people who maybe aren't so
like-minded but they allow me to say my
thoughts yeah that's what I like about
it too is that it really is the
embodiment of just homies kicking it in
a parking lot talking and then I used to
be like that with Quest Crew we had that
same Dynamic so to do that there it felt
exactly the same to me uh it is hard to
get your I guess to find the pockets in
the first time you're there like the
first time I was there I was like when
do I even speak because I want to
interrupt you I don't want to interrupt
Joe or Bart and then after some time it
becomes like super easy but um yeah I
just enjoyed it a lot like watching it
and being part of it that's the hard
part that pocket when you if if anybody
who ever happens to come on JK news as I
guess in the future finding your pocket
in JK news is hard because you have to
always be on your toes yeah right like
being on your toes is like uh I had my
buddy Khalif came on and I remember yeah
as a guest he was off for like 20
episodes and he didn't say one word
let's just plead the fifth they're like
dude I've never seen a JK news episode
without a guest
hey Khalifa's like I can't believe I
came on there and that's back when the
audience was like ruthless too yeah the
comment section was toxic as hell you
know I went to Community College with
Khalif oh really yeah dude what the [__]
a small ass World dude yeah like when I
was still trying trying to dance I would
practice in the student center at
Cypress College and he would just be
hanging out there too and then I didn't
see him again until like years and years
later what when he was like yo bro yeah
and I didn't know that he was buddies
with you I seen him later because I
started a a photo studio in downtown and
he was talent that had worked there and
he brought some like iguana or some [__]
oh his gecko his Gekko yeah yeah and
then I ran into him and I was like oh
[__] what the hell we haven't seen each
other since like 2003. that's [__] what
a small [__] world oh man yeah
because he still lives at the place that
I used to live because we we were
roommates oh yeah so khalif's story was
at the top for me and him was that he uh
obviously wanted to be an actor he's
still yeah pursuing acting now
um
and he used to he was in a sketch of
mine and I found out through just having
conversation with him that he was
sleeping in his car because he was
living out in Long Beach and in order to
get to all these auditions it would just
make more sense for him to sleep there
damn yeah in order for him not to miss
his auditions because of traffic and
stuff yeah so he just sleep in his class
like bro don't sleep in your car
whenever you're in town just sleep at my
side right so if you have like auditions
in the morning the next day are meetings
just come here park your car crash here
and then it's all about so at that point
we just became really close he's such a
[__] nice guy he is super nice he's a
great dude yeah he's he's he like I mean
you'll see some of our text messages
pretty [__] up but that's when you
know you have a really good [__]
friend yeah yeah yeah yeah but everybody
is like somehow because dude the thing
that blew my [__] mind on JK news is
when you told me about the connection
that you and Joe had that blew my mind
because it happened in front of my
[__] face yeah bro that happened in
front of my face he was he literally had
said to me what do you know about that
Joe mama guy and I was like I I just
knew he was scary I never met today and
he's looking me in the face and he goes
I'm Joe mama like I'm so sorry how often
does that ever happen in life when
you're looking at the guy and he's like
that was me do you have any idea how
much of a menace you have to be to
create a legend about what I'm saying
yeah I would see him all the time
standing in the on the campus because
he's visiting and everybody would be
like oh that's that crazy fool
people don't know like just in general
Joe has
matured so much since even the first day
I met him right even from when the first
day I met him people said that that was
actually a calmer version of it when I
first met him I thought he was a
psychopath like Joe
so we were at the um the San Diego Asian
film festival yeah and
um we're watching this Jackie Chan movie
and a bunch of Chinese letters come down
right and then out of nowhere Joe's
sitting next to me man I can't read
[Laughter]
vlog
and you know the
the blame this I laugh not because I
because I looked at his face and he
wasn't making a joke yeah like he's not
heckling he's he's not laughing at he's
just sitting there he looks visibly
upset I'm like
bro this guy is hilarious and he doesn't
even know it yeah and I'm cracking the
[__] up and this lady next to me hey can
you tell your friend to shut up I was
like excuse me that is not my friend
I denounced him immediately uh I don't
know any Japs thanks yeah yeah let me
tell you something I'm Korean and I hope
he dies
I'm waiting for my reparations I also
would like to kill him yeah I was a
comfort woman
you know what I can't wrap my head
around how uh so
with Quest Crew and how long I've known
Victor and how long I lived with the guy
how the [__] did I not meet you way back
then I don't we always just kept missing
each other yeah so so if you guys
remember Victor Kim
um Quest Crew that obviously right the
hollow back everything that was his
thing he always when we were kids he
would just do that for no [__] reason
hey Victor can you get that
picture
uh you still didn't get the pencil but
thanks yeah it's been about 10 minutes
can you just pick it up I got it he's
bending as hard as he could
but he um yeah so my mom is super close
friends with his mom yeah so we grew up
together uh occasionally he used to go
to this uh church called Arc Mission out
in Sacramento and my cousin went there
so I used to attend that church every
now and then if I spent the night at my
at my cousin's house is that part of the
unification Church yeah exactly we um
and you know Victor when I like we were
so [__] different right uh yeah uh
I'm I'm super loud super Brash and
Victor's a very sensitive [__] yeah
soft-spoken very soft-spoken and when
you have that type of like calm energy
with my chaos there's always one person
that's gonna get their feelings hurt and
it's not me
so I used to genuinely hurt that those
feelings early for [__] time but like
you know for me as somebody as a younger
person we're like Korean people are so
good at [__] with each other yeah
yeah yeah yeah right so I would get
[__] with I would [__] with other
people whoever ends it just never ends
and so I remember this is a very clear
moment of mine I've told you I think
I've told you this before where I made
fun of him because he made this YouTube
video where he would turn around and
he'd be like hi I didn't see you guys
there and I was like yeah if you didn't
see us who the [__] set up the camera
dude oh that doesn't make any [__] I'm
like roasting this whole during
Thanksgiving
he gets up and he just leaves
and I was like oh [__] I can't make fun
of him like that I didn't know but
everybody's laughing he's not laughing
so I felt super [__] bad and I never
did it again yeah he was really
sensitive about his craft and stuff
especially at that point when he started
to sing more he was very sensitive about
that [__] like we learned too not to do
that yeah and you know listen I love the
guy who wasn't the best singer though
yeah I mean man I had to listen to that
[__] you you had a little snippet of it
for like a couple of years imagine that
since like Church times he was like a
praise leader man [__] I don't
think God is feeling praise right now
you really didn't like his singing no I
didn't know I was like God damn [__] bro
God's angry right now you're going to
hell yeah yeah so you can imagine when
it's like growing up with somebody like
me and you're that [__] sense yeah
yeah yeah that's rough people would get
you know like on Church [__] you would
get ripped apart dude you would just I
remember this guy gave me a purple
nurple so bad it bruised my whole chest
oh my God he literally in church and in
church
praise the Lord
he had his knee on my stomach and this
full twisted my titties so hard my whole
chest was bruised the next day
the whole [__] thing and this guy I
think he was I was used to get
augmentation surgery to fix it that's
why nobody has seen me without a shirt
yeah my nipples are huge
you should go to botched and be like hey
somebody [__] this up man fix it I
couldn't imagine myself just telling
this sad story so I was a little boy at
church
and he twisted so hard
it's like this is a weird story just the
counselors want to laugh
yes yes okay yeah but we used to get
punked at church so much
um and he was also a part of that too
yeah yeah his older brother too his
older brother used to punk me his older
brother one time I went over to his
house by the way dopest dude ever like
shout out like so dope
he um used to fix our computers he was
super good with that [__] so I brought
over a laptop of mine for him to help
fix yeah but at the time he was so like
trying to get into the military
everything he did was military [__] so I
come into the house true story darkest
[__] I don't know what the [__] I was
like hello
don't know
it tackles me I'm screaming right I get
hogtied with zip ties like this and
grabs my laptop I'm [__] crying I'm
young at this time I don't know what the
[__] is happening right I'm like
and then next thing you know he
good likes comes on he comes out he
unties me goes I fix your computer
you're good to go he was different you
know what I'm saying cuckoo actions bro
bro I have some funny stories about him
I will tell all of them because
obviously I don't know if he's that
comfortable I won't tell those stories
but he but that's like Korean hazing
type of [__] he was intense oh but you
know he was always sweet and kind to me
though like it was really cool he fixed
my [__] computer right
I just can't imagine like what if you
went to Geek Squad they did the same
[__]
hello
no that's how everyone fixes computers
she's like you guys don't get your
computer when I go to Geek Squad I lay
on the floor in my stomach yeah ready
you guys don't get hogtied when your
hard drive doesn't detect you said you
were a Seventh-Day Adventist like Joe
was right oh yes SDA I actually don't
know any person besides you and Joe that
was a Seventh Day Adventist really you
never met any others no there's so many
Asian SDA people I I don't know what was
that like bro it's you know what's funny
is a lot of people will tell that story
like it's something super crazy it's
just kind of inconvenient being SDA but
it's not that bad like the big
difference is that you can't do anything
on Saturdays so like can't work for
instance I didn't I didn't know there
was an X-Men cartoon on Saturday
mornings because it I just never saw it
so when kids would go oh yeah X-Men
cartoon I go you guys are lying there's
no X-Men cartoon so you're telling me
it's it there's these things that move
on a screen that aren't people
it's just like I think maybe like if you
were an SDA in the olden days it's way
more crazier but in modern times it's
just inconvenient like uh yeah the
Saturday thing the also one of the
roughest things is how they kind of not
every sect will preach this but there's
a kind of an unspoken hatred for other
religions the wheels yeah just because
it's like oh they're all going to hell
kind of deal
because like anything to justify that
you're the correct one right my brother
in Christ have a good morning
[Laughter]
that's like when you read fortune
cookies you add the thing at the end why
are you doing good things anyways you're
going to hell yeah it is that it's like
really really odd yeah when it's a tiny
community and everything it's it's
different wait what's the reason why you
guys can't do anything on Saturdays uh
because Saturday is like the holy day of
worship and anything you do on Saturdays
has to be god-based so the funny thing
is there's little loopholes like you'll
just get bible-based board games like
every board game you can think of has a
Christian version of it so you just
break those out on Saturday and you're
like oh we're playing Bible
mousetrapy
you could only bake a cake in the shape
of a cross
you gotta make it Jesus head that's way
longer hey kids we're only having bread
and fish today and somehow I gotta
multiply it for everybody yeah this is
gonna be hard yeah kids only drink wine
you only have two barley loaves yeah but
watch I'm Jesus Christ we don't even eat
those
we are this week only Ezekiel Bread the
worst bread ever
yeah it's great and plus like a lot of
SDA uh people are vegetarian oh so
there's yeah you're not gonna like that
part that's super hard for me man like I
uh you know I could do pescetarian yeah
yeah I don't know if like vegetarian
vegan is [__] hard man it is hard
yeah it's just because like I just want
to try different things right and I
can't be in the same [__] over and over
and over again I even get titled with
that with like meat I can't even meet
over and over and over again I get
[__] exhausted I wanna eat other [__]
yeah I don't know how people do that
dude I don't either the biggest thing
probably for me personally with SDA
religion was the fact that some of the
laws are so old like uh the dancing law
like you can't dance was the weirdest
thing to me but they danced in the Bible
I guess so but like they don't allow it
in the culture of like today they're
like oh no dancing so like if you go to
a you don't think you have prom to our
high school had banquet where it was
like a danceless prom
and uh and if you're like having worship
service and there's guitar and there's
like there's a rhythm you can't like
move to the Rhythm you have to like
suppress that and just like
but they literally that's like
I mean I don't know that's biblically
encouraged biblical proof that David
danced like exactly everything it's like
biblically incorrect I think it's the
fact that it's not dancing for the Lord
like it has to be for the Lord so if I
wanted to go and like train dancing for
myself then that's like a secular act so
that it's like like religious like
absolutism like listen I commend people
for that because that's actually very
hard to live that way yeah you know to
to follow everything if I catch you
eating a shrimp I'm beating that ass
then right if I couldn't dance and I see
you eat that shrimp cocktail
I didn't even have a shrimp until I was
like 22 or some [__] holy [__] I didn't
even have a lobster until I was in my
mid-20s you couldn't have so you didn't
have pork either then you can't no you
can't have four kids you can't have uh
shellfish yeah bottom feeding animals
cloven Hooves oh my God no catfish no
cat I still haven't had catfish you
don't need to I'm not missing it
did you ever have catfish
nah get in here are you good get in here
hey shrimp I understand I created that
really delicious
that was the hardest part was just the
dance side of it which did make sense to
me and then you know there was a
religion too that there was a girl in
high school that she was a part of I
think it was called Iglesia and Julio
yeah
she also couldn't dance so during our
prom she would just like not dance and I
didn't know what it was about so she
wasn't allowed to dance so she just
dressed up and she just partook in like
prom that allowed that the religion was
called Iglesia yeah it's like a it's
like a Philip a lot of Filipinos are
part of it actually because there's a
well I don't know if it's related but
there are Seventh-day Adventist churches
that are called Iglesia something or
maybe it was something it could have
been just a Spanish Church it probably
was that yeah because I dated a girl who
was also a part of that and she would
told me like I couldn't dance uh with
anybody they have like these very strict
rules with like Elders in the church
yeah who gives more money has more power
in the church the tithe is really
serious oh so maybe that was seventh day
yeah the Tiding the tithing it's it'll
be like a direct deposit like it'll be
taken out of your check before you get
your check so like you'll sign up for
tithing to your church they will take 10
of your paycheck and then when you see
your balance it's like already missing
you know what that's dedication but
that's tightening be hella hard for me
dude because I've been going to church
and I'd be tithing that solid two
dollars
I I tied a dollar every week when I was
a kid and as a full-grown adult two
bucks baby let's go well I mean that
would be a lot if you know if there was
never inflation from the Bible times
it's like well like I guess I'm giving
less than I did when I was a kid yeah
you're incrementally donating less and
less yeah I haven't really found a
church that I've been hyper dedicated to
so it's hard to tithe to a a church that
I that I really back right now was your
denomination growing up just straight
Christian it was a presbyterian oh okay
yeah and then my father when he started
his own church and I wanted to get into
Ministry it was non-denominational oh
wow so for those of you who aren't
religious like different denominations
have a different way the churches ran
right so there's Baptist there's
Presbyterian some people have a system
of Elders some people don't uh
non-denomination is just whatever the
the people decide yeah it's like
Freestyle worship exactly so they just
get into a [__] thing
I think you going to Hell
Brain Stone
they just do terrible spoken word
against each other yeah yeah growing up
in religion's rough man I give it up for
people that stick with it you know so
when did you uh you stopped going to
obviously right because you being shrimp
and [__] going to hell yeah I mean
that's I feel like the biggest thing
where I had to really turn my back on it
was just wanting to be a dancer as odd
and dumb as that sounds that's right
like that sounds so stupid but it's true
it's like I had to keep it a secret that
I was training in dance and I got
written up in school like uh I I got a
pink slit for dancing in the gym which
was really just me practicing windmills
it wasn't like I was gyrating or like
twerking and cleaning the floor guys and
then I got a pink slip sent home and my
my parents were like
what are you doing like you're getting
trouble for what exactly and then they
were like no more of that and so I had
to keep it a secret and then secret was
out when I tried out for So You Think
You Can Dance 2005 and then I was on TV
hold on a second the sequence when you
went to So You Think You Can Dance
that's pretty much when they were like
oh you're really you were really taking
that seriously because they would see
like they would see like little tidbits
of me like it's I can't hide it all the
time but then that was when they were
like possible yeah why is it grabbing
the form like potatoes
what was that yeah
it was like that was when it was like
the family you know like nothing's that
big of a deal until your whole family
knows and then that's where they have to
bear the shame to the family of like oh
he really my son dances yeah my son is
gay
why do you care that I dance so much I
don't care you are gay God I'm not gay
I'm just a dancer he's like you got the
one or the other
well I guess that's the first of that
kind
maybe it is dead
yeah you start walking out here
right it was really that comical like
it's so like melodramatic but like it's
such a stupid thing to have to like be
having turmoil over you know what was
the conversation when your parents found
out that you were on like so you think
you could dance and you're oh bro you're
[__] excelling at it by the way it's
funny because they were like one of the
things was like they had seen the
episode come out where I kind of talk
about my home story so I talk about like
how I was raised and everything and I'd
mentioned the stuff about religion and
my parents they were more mad about that
than anything else they were just like
hey don't don't say that stuff anymore
I don't care you want to suck you want
to [__] whatever just don't tell people
we're bad parents
yeah hey what the [__]
yeah that's it they were just mad about
that just the interview Parts they were
just like whatever because I think by
then they knew that the form of dancing
that I wanted to do wasn't didn't
directly correlate with the kind in the
Bible because in the Bible and kind of
like an essay belief it's that dancing
leads to sexual degeneracy and they were
like oh you're not getting laid with any
of those moves
nice try what if I before I did a woman
I said Jesus Christ
that's that dude's work around there
yeah it's like you want to see Jesus
Christ yo he's actually got an OG OG so
before he went to prison like the dance
community in Sacramento knew who he was
but he's the the Jesus Christ guy oh
that guy he's like legit really he was
like legit I didn't know that yeah he's
a Sacramento dude uh I heard about him
in Sacramento years ago I'm not sure if
he's like from Sacramento but people
knew of him in the scene oh wow so when
he popped up like I didn't realize just
until you know my buddy Vince was like
do you remember this guy I don't oh yeah
oh that's right he's like an OG wow so
after he went to prison I don't know
what but he just came out just pop pop
yeah Jesus yeah yeah I mean that's great
man if you can if that'll help your life
that's dope what year did you go into so
you think you could dance 2005 that was
like the year yeah you broke your
parents heart dude yeah yeah and they
were like we've lost him forever to the
lgbts
right
yeah that was that was that year and
then after that I just started uh
teaching and that was kind of my career
was just dance based for all the years
after that what was the conversation
that you had with him after you got done
with it and you came back home I almost
kind of never had a straight up
conversation with him because like my
shit's I mean I'm so like Asian that you
know my the disconnect between parent
and kid like I don't have conversations
like that with them just like little uh
non-verbal acknowledgments you know like
my parents they came to like one of the
tapings and that's kind of how I knew
that it was like okay we're cool you
know they're not totally you know and
then by the time we did Best Dance Crew
with like Victor and Quest and everybody
they they were pretty supportive and
they came to those two wow but that's
like [__] four or five years later so
you know I bet you what it was though
it's like At first it's shame and they
find out that it's pretty cool and then
people are super supportive of it and
they're like I told you he's better
yeah that's my boy it makes a big
difference too like once uh a Filipino
publication picks it up then it's like
mixtv got it yeah yeah
once once we were on like uh like ASAP
in the Philippines and just like when I
went to the Philippines and did stuff
there then it was like okay now it's
fine you know because you know they're
gonna take the stance of like yeah I I
taught him everything yeah
that was like my dad I killed him follow
your dream
[Laughter]
five years ago he had underground
dancing move I told him do that he tried
to be a nurse I said [__] no
you're just sitting in the back like
yeah and of course I just go with it
because I'm like anything to just be
peaceful whatever I have it if that
makes you happy whatever as long as I
get to [__] dance I don't give a [__]
yeah but it was a little bit weird
because after in between so you think
you could dance and ABDC I actually went
back to school because my mom what was
always asking like hey you ever gonna
get your college diploma or whatever and
then I applied to UCI and that's how I
ended up living with Victor because I
ended up going to UC Irvine after so you
think and that was weird because people
were like what are you doing here dude
yeah yeah but I was like oh I just want
to kind of finish my my schooling up and
then a quarter or like one semester
before I was going to graduate then
America's Best Dance career happened so
I had to leave my transcript Frozen
anyway so I never I never graduated UCI
I never graduated from college either
really I had um like a like a semester
or a quarter left oh yeah and I just
left I just said I don't need this [__]
for comedy I went to a comedy College
Doug I [__] uh so I was in uh UCR uh
got into trouble over there I left came
to figure out my life figure out oh
that's right yeah UCR yeah and then I
went to
um went back to Sacramento Community
College and then I switched over to Sac
State and then I had a little bit left
before I was going to graduate and I
literally walked it I had a test I
forgot what it was for it was like a
blue book test I just drew a big old
smiley face in it closed it left and I
dropped out what the heck and I just
dropped out and I said I can't do this
anymore
I pursued Comedy full time then my
[__] YouTube [__] blew up and then I
was like oh I'm gonna move I'm gonna
sell everything I don't need anything
else I came straight to La just started
doing stand-up damn dude I just imagine
I wish it was like you were in college
and your teachers were just like you're
too funny David you got to get out of
here you gotta get the [__] out of here
man hey man you're dumb as [__] this is
not for you yeah the blue book is upside
down
you've been misspelling your name the
entire time here also this is the wrong
class
also this is a Sac State I'm like where
am I this is DeVry yeah this is DeVry
University you might have been enrolled
in here yeah
you're like I think I should do comedy
where am I that's dope though that you
you actually got that far and then you
know yeah man I just didn't
I you know what it was it's just that
whole thing of battling your parents the
whole time yeah you I only stayed in
college to do everything that my parents
wanted right because I like my mom was
like honestly my Saving Grace because
she was like just do this for your dad
get this [__] degree right do
whatever you want after but it was so
hard for me because I didn't care yeah
but that's the heartstring man do it for
your dad yeah that's the heartstrings so
I kept doing it and then I when I
dropped out dude that was a disaster
like my debt me and my dad's
relationship was [__] terrible for
years it just didn't it wouldn't fit and
then things came to a head it exploded
and then we finally figured it out but
then my mom was always the one that was
just like supporting me on the low yeah
so you could do whatever you want like
you just need to do this right on the
low because if it wasn't for her I don't
I think I would have lost my [__]
mind like I don't think I would have
ever talked to my parents ever again
like me and my dad would have never had
our bond if it wasn't for my mom because
she was the one that was supporting me
so it's like it it was just so [__]
difficult like I just I mean even for
you like you already technically had
your foot in the door and you still
completed that well almost completed
[__] which was crazy to me yeah I mean
the moment that little success happened
I was like I'm out dude you know yeah it
was it sucked too because I got into UCI
on a full ride so I wasn't paying for
anything so it was even more
heartbreaking for my parents that I quit
when I had such a good opportunity it's
like I blew it you know what I mean like
how many people get that chance and then
you know
I just left yeah what was the whole like
So You Think You Can Dance Experience
like was it it you know what it's so
crazy because that was back when reality
TV was like the [__] you know what I
mean I love that show I love so you
think you could dance I love America's
Best Dance Crew it was different back
then like there was no and there was no
way to you know what's interesting there
was no way to quantify how how like
known you got because it's not like we
had social media numbers so like you
would just do the TV show and you'd walk
outside and some people would recognize
you some people wouldn't but you had no
idea where that was yeah yeah just like
having people know who I was for the
first time in my life was just like it
was a crazy identity crisis
um it was like here you got a bunch of
people that like you and think they know
you and it's really fun and it's cool
but like also
it always bugged me that uh it was just
over dance which is kind of weird uh
that's and that's the reason why I told
Barton Joe this when they first asked me
to like be on JK
um kind of like for the long run I was
like honestly like for the first time
ever I like that I can actually talk oh
because so much of everything I did was
just movement based or action-based or
image and then like no one ever gave a
[__] about what I thought about anything
you know that's so [__] interesting
dude because I feel like
one of the hardest things because
dancing kind of technically like well
you might purchase like a sport right
yeah yeah it's
people who are in sports have a very
hard time dealing with the fact that
their body one day will break down oh
yeah it's rough and a lot of dancers
that I know have an identity crisis once
they start losing that ability and they
don't know what to do anymore because
this is everything to them right they
identify as the person who can dance
once that beat gets taken away from you
and it'll happen there are a few
anomalies out there that like just as
well as they did when they were in their
50s like it's rare better than ever
somehow exactly I don't [__] get it
but it happens right
um so for you to kind of understand that
and then I'm just like although I got
more [__] than just the dance part is
something that I don't get to see a lot
because I have a lot of friends who are
in dance and I see like their shell of
themselves now because they always talk
about when I used to be able to do this
when I used to be it's all Glory Day
based conversation yeah yeah it's like
bro you're 400 pounds now dude I don't
know what the [__] tell you oh just
wait till my comeback bro just just wait
why don't you [__] get out of the
[__] McDonald's first and then we'll
talk to you fat [__] put down the fish
fillets yeah hey back in my day I used
to you know come on bro right right like
I used to be super fat I know what
that's like you ain't doing [__] yeah
yeah that's the crazy thing about it is
like we for so long we had just worked
gig to Gig and uh just everything was
dance based and my interests were very
music based and writing I went to uh
University for journalism like that's my
favorite thing and I never really got a
professional opportunity to do anything
that wasn't dance based so I always felt
like I mistook my worth for being like
in that Department of like oh if I'm not
doing that then what am I offering you
know so it was it was cool the first
time I ever went on JK when and you were
there and I was like dude that's dope I
didn't even have to nobody was like Hey
do it do a move you know what I mean
like it was just so nice and chill how
annoying is that [__] right like you're
just trying to chill you're right and
they're like dude can you land on your
Achilles tendon again can you turn your
ACL real quick
hey I know that your meniscus is gone
yeah but do that thing again for me it's
like bro it's yeah I mean it's like it's
it's like a thing where if you get mad
at that then I think it's also unfair
because that's that's what it is you
know it is what it is but I used to hate
when you know they would like find out
your stand-up comments hey can you make
me laugh and I'm like I can't because
you're already a joke get the [__] out
of my face like oh he's kind of mean and
I'm like bro if I would tell you to do
your job in front of me right now how
would you feel that's that that's that's
like the main response is that like
dancers will always say like what do you
do for work and like Oh I'm a plumber
can you just go unclog my toilet right
now you know but it's it is I get it
because like it's hard because we would
always go to Red Carpet things for like
MTV events or like really prestigious
things and as soon as if you're a dancer
and there were very few dance
celebrities in that era as soon as
you're on the red carpet what do they
all say do a move do a thing like and
they're like on your spine again yeah
and they won't take your picture until
you do a thing and it's like it makes
you feel like a monkey doing tricks you
know which it's like I get it but but
also at the same time it's rough yeah
you can say there's not like we're not
appreciative of like the opportunities
that we have but sometimes it's hard to
just like you know can can we just talk
for a second yeah and then maybe if I
want to I'll do it because you know we
we can't always have our job coat on all
the time yeah can I say something that's
kind of [__] up oh please I uh like
I've always felt a little bit like
dissed by the Asian Gala Community
because anytime we were invited to Asian
Excellence events we were always
performing oh can I say something
they're all [__] trash anyways thank
you right okay I wanted to connect with
you on that because I feel like you have
the same like sense to tell you
something dude
laughs
I've been invited to those things
multiple times and I've said no every
[__] time wow I I haven't been
invited now for like a few years right
because obviously I'm pretty actually
vocal about how dumb I think they are
yeah um and I'm not saying about the
people who do it or whatever but these
events are so [__] snobby and
literally a dick sucking event for
people who said that okay we started
this so we could have our space and we
want to be inclusive right the the
problem that I have with these all with
these events too it's they're doing the
exact same thing that they said that
they hated Hollywood for you create this
event to show people that you are better
than somebody else when the reason why
you said you created these events is to
celebrate and kind of bring everybody in
but you're not yeah you're only bringing
people in that make your quote-unquote
community look great right there are
people in this community that if you're
it's really about Asian Excellence if
that's what you're about that are
outside of entertainment that you should
be celebrating yeah yeah and look I'm
also in the acting field right but let's
be real we play pretend for a [__]
living what the [__] do we do are we
saving lives you know what I'm saying
are we really like huge acts what the
[__] are we you know what I'm saying
yeah we play pretend and we do it really
well and it's good
so if you're doing these events to talk
about Asian Excellence there are so many
people out there that should be
celebrated and I will say this too like
a lot of people may not like somebody
like China Mac but when people are being
burned out in these middle in these
streets China map was out there protest
doing something he was doing something
yeah he has never been invited to that
event why because he doesn't fit this
perfect box of what Asian Excellence is
so I think that those [__] events are
[__] stupid you guys are [__]
absolute [__] if I ever get invited
I will show up and I'm going to
embarrass the [__] out of all of you God
that would be so great here's the thing
too
and I've talked about this was this was
at the time this event was called the
coryam gala right and I was so I was
invited to present an award to PSY right
clearly because I looked like him I get
it fine you guys got me
right
and I remember there was like I'm not
gonna say these names obviously but just
watching people come up to me and say
all this dope stuff and they know that
I'm very opinionated and they're like
talking [__] about somebody else to me
as if I give a [__] I think it's really
weird in the first place I don't even
know you yeah and I see him walk over to
that person bro I [__] appreciate you
I see what you're doing out here what
the [__] did you just say to me and I'm
gonna just watch this I'm like oh you
guys are all garbage yeah they're all
garbage human beings and then I would
see this [__] where um there was this
girl that was behind me you know she's a
pretty prominent actress
and she's talking about how she can't
wait to find the right one to give her
virginity to and I just wanted to turn
around and be like you sucked one of my
friends off in the back of his car
you guys were smashing for months what
and she openly voluntarily told this
person nobody asked her she was talking
about her love for Christ and how you
know what like she can't wait to like
give her virginity to the person that
she loves nobody asked her at the table
and people are entertaining her and then
afterwards I'm like
what world do I live in it's just image
building like constant bro I was
gathering material all day just eating
my Laura's Prime ribs
[Laughter]
what else is going to say just soaking
it all up I [__] dumb dude hey it was
actually a little bit of like my reason
of hating Hollywood it's like even when
people say that they're trying to do
better it's all lip service right I'm
not saying that there aren't great
people that I know that are actors and
actresses they are there yeah but I
guarantee you they're not partaking in
that [__] nah yeah I always thought
it was so weird because in at least in
my experience as a as a gig worker like
when we were Quest Crew taking all the
gigs that we possibly could we got paid
full rate from like white companies
black companies whenever it was an Asian
client in any capacity it was always
cool to do it for the culture do it for
free do it for a reduced amount hey
let's help each other we'll we'll trade
opportunities there was always some kind
of snag and it was never just pay the
price it was always something else but
people don't ever want to talk about
this yeah they don't I've never heard
anyone openly say that and I thought it
was really [__] up they think like and
also too like I'm always super against
this type of [__] this is why when
people tell me I have to like something
because it's Asian I hate that [__] I
[__] hate it dude and I will say I'll
if I openly love something I'll support
the [__] [__] out of it people have
seen me give so much praise to all these
great Asian films and the Shang Chi
comes around and I give it an open and
honest review yeah right and you watched
a shitload more than people that like it
exactly right and I'm breaking it down I
don't remember [__] about that film
anymore but at the time like I was like
shocked at how bad it was you know how
[__] terrible it was yeah and so and
I explained myself pretty [__] well
me and my buddy Ed right and he's a film
buff yeah yeah yeah yeah and I was
suddenly this like I can't believe
you're [__] on Asian culture I'm
like I don't remember the last time well
I didn't know that I was living in a
[__] iron castle and this guy doing
Kung Fu this is not my culture it's a
[__] movie and a bad one at that
my culture [__] are you talking about
dude yeah isn't that what all Sacramento
Koreans do yeah I had no idea yeah and
then what happened everything everywhere
all at once came out yeah glowing review
hey thank you for that hey by the way
exactly yes and by the way I did my part
I didn't trash [__] uh crazy Rich
Asians I didn't trash it and I wanted
you so bad oh you did I wanted to I
didn't what did you not like about it it
was garbage
it was some of the worst writing the
tackiest [__] jokes it was just
absolutely terrible it was one pun lines
that didn't [__] make sense these
weird [__] caricatures I don't know
who the [__] it was trying to represent
like what the [__] was it the acting was
terrible because the writing was
terrible so it wasn't even the the
actor's fault and you never did a video
reviewing it or anything no I I decided
to keep that one quite because it was
the first of its kind but after a few
months passed I'm like we've had enough
and I like it to say my [__] you know
what I'm saying yeah just give it some
time wait till like it accumulates
because now we have a lot of
opportunities yeah people are seeing a
lot of film like first of all there has
been a lot of great Asian films that
isn't Asian American necessarily right
you got to talk about somebody like Juan
car why one of the greatest
cinematographers of our times like are
you [__] nuts you know what I'm
saying like Korean Cinema has been
around for a very [__] long time so
I've seen a lot of great people that
look just like me yeah do great [__]
things right so just because you didn't
necessarily see it doesn't it never
existed you're only talking about this
because you never saw it and it's it's
also tough too when you think about
Asian American life and how few movies
they are that actually correlate
directly to that specific guy like to me
when I was a teenager probably the
closest movie to and this is incorrect
obviously but I felt more closely
connected to [__] Fast and Furious
than I did like another like Joy Luck
Club or something you know what I mean
because to me it's like that that import
scene to me was the Asian Community when
I was a teenager yeah that is that
that's why [__] what's it called uh
the one I wonder
that one was the most Teriyaki voice
exactly oh God that was the most low
budget one that actually saved the
franchise yeah yeah because it related
to like the Asian Americans at the time
it was the [__] import model girls
yeah all of the [__] the Supras the
GTRs right all these cards that we
[__] love and that's what we really
and I understand if like of I don't know
some Asian film buff person who was
never part of that Community looks at it
and goes that's all superficial [__]
and it's like yeah but it meant a lot to
us as odd as that sounds yeah you know
what I mean so like I said even with
something like Shang Chi right no I
never told anybody you can't like it I'm
just tell you how I feel about it right
and so people say well I liked it I'm
like that's great that's a good thing
yeah yeah what the [__] like I'm not I'm
not trying to take her it's not a debate
yeah exactly it's not a debate there's
no moral stance on this right it's a
movie review it's a movie review yes all
that it [__] is dude shout out to
[__] semen Lube man my [__] my guy
bro you always say his name wrong what
do you mean
I I just do it just because people have
egged me on so much it just makes me
laugh so hard and I just one day I just
want somebody to come up to him and just
say it just because it's so funny to me
it makes me laugh I know I can be an
[__] sometimes
I mean that's great I think it's so
funny the whole Ruddy thing even when
you came on JK and you talked about it
people people think like I hate this
like I don't hate I just think that he
just really dumb things yeah it's for
somebody that's you know if you could
just do your work and let your work
shout for itself because right now
you're just known as the guy that
complains like look we all say weird
things and I get it he has his Great
Moments right but the idea that you're
an actor and you're not known for your
acting is weird to me
you know what that's a really good point
you know because nobody has ever said
dude seamless acting is amazing
even you saying that just
just making a joke
and people don't understand like
I'm hyper supportive of so many Asian
people right but when they do dumb [__]
like he has done right like trying to
make these issues about him rather than
the actual culture I don't like people
who take a Hot Topic and make an actual
problem that we're trying to solve about
them so they could boost their platform
does the Asian Community have a Denzel
where it's like his acting is just the
Forefront of why people love them
you know but people don't give this man
a lot of credit but he's actually I mean
he's not even Asian American he's I
think he's from Benedict Wong he's
actually one of my favorites he's so
[__] good people don't ever give him
credit I love that guy he's like one of
the biggest reasons why I still want to
act right is because of somebody like
him people need to give that man his due
Justice if you see him in any of his
short films his films he's actually a
theatrical actor okay his theater he's
amazing you know what I mean like I
don't know who that is but I have my
personal favorite like Asian actors and
they're all Koreans this guy temin Chic
he did um old boy oh okay so he's my
favorite like when I see him act it
makes me want to work hard to be at his
caliber uh so you know I do have my own
personal Heroes right and one of the
best things that my buddy Justin Chon
you know shout out to Justin has told me
he goes like look if if you or anybody
else thinks that you're a great actor
here's what you should say to yourself
if you stood next or if you were in an
acting scene next to your favorite actor
on Earth the best like you look up to
this person do you think that you can
stand with that person line for line if
the answer is no then go get to work
all right I'm like oh [__] wow that's
real like I've never said I'm a good
actor because I don't think I could I
think that I I've been very blessed to
have these roles that kind of suit my
personality like if I had to play like a
cop that had saved somebody's life you
better I can't do that that's hard yeah
that's like when when uh when Tim was
saying that he was he was up for that
role in that that Thai movie about
saving the the kids from the things yeah
yeah yeah and then he tried to do that
he had to be like a southern type yeah
it's like that's too many layers man
that's so hard it's a lot of cops
that's a mighty it's hard when people
like are are so used to seeing your face
and then like connecting that with
laughter like oh I'm gonna laugh when I
see this guy that's why it was really
hard with [__] like when we made this
that's why it was also [__] dope
people couldn't wrap their head around
it at first I [__] myself when I saw
that because like I was like I'd never
seen you do that yeah it was my first
time being able to like I actually like
dramatic acting way more than like
comedic acting a thousand percent for
the rest of my life if I was in acting
roles I would not do comedy I would just
do dramatic acting yeah it's just um it
requires a lot out of you and like the
end result is very impactful not to say
I don't like comedy like I [__] love
it yeah but comedy's in my wheel back so
if I could do dramatic acting I could I
would do that for the rest of my life
I'm like Asian agentless right now agent
right now no no age damn yeah I'm taking
a Hiatus and I don't know if I ever want
to go back to it what the [__] are you
serious yeah like I'm not sure if I want
to because I really like
my freedom wow dude I don't like
somebody dictating how I should behave
act and feel when it's not honest like
being like a z-list celebrity is the
ultimate Freedom that's great huh it's
the best z-list people don't always say
your z-list though hey I like it though
yeah celebrity is [__] fantastic
you're trying to maintain the z a clean
Z no matter what I don't want to go any
higher than a zealous celebrity right
because I get to maintain my lifestyle I
have a great relationship with my fan
base and I get to create things and I'm
allowed to make mistakes and not be
[__] sacrificed right and people have
seen me on this podcast apologize I said
this [__] wild [__] the last time hey
I apologize and I'm allowed to do that
yeah that's true yeah I mean like people
feel like the word sorry doesn't exist
anymore yeah it almost like got removed
from Webster's yeah it's like yeah I
wish I could go through your text
messages and see you're [__] up
everybody's got [__] up [__] yeah
because we're normal yeah we're not
gonna say perfect things so I want I was
like if anybody does that I'm like show
me your phone I want to see your crazy
[__] dude in that dude you wouldn't be
able to survive that would be the great
evening of society I know yeah that'd be
crazy we saw so much of that [__] and
that version of that that was online
when people were trying to crucify each
other was going through people's Twitter
oh God yeah Twitter the great Twitter
scrub each person was just like
frantically trying to delete everything
two of the scariest words this you
question mark
have you ever had a dreams
it was a different time yeah you stupid
[__] turns out that you're human just
like me did you guys ever have to do
that with JK like because you guys did
so many freaking episodes and it was so
free uh I guess like you guys said
whatever the [__] you wanted for so long
JK news was harp because sometimes the
comments were really [__] harsh and
dude yeah that era when I first would
come on as a guest the comments were
crazy over nothing like nothing at all
they would just everyone just hate
everything got one of the funniest
things let me tell you one of the the
comments that used that cracked me up
that I still remember so back in the day
uh Tommy you guys if you guys used to
watch JK news from the from the from the
onset of it there was a guy named Tommy
he was a videographer very [__]
talented right Tommy Trin
Tommy would always start these stories
that would go [__] nowhere okay like
he would start and like it's something
that Nick used to do back and I used to
roast them all the time
like he doesn't do it anymore but they
would start a story and were like where
the [__] is this coin like half the time
when he would talk I wanted to open up
Google Maps and just give it to him he's
like tell me where this is going
what you know and so what we would do is
that we would cut him off and then you
know finish it off so like we could
complete his story so he doesn't look
like a [__] idiot right you would
just edit his whole thing so these
comments would come in and they would be
like dude you guys always cut off Tommy
like this it's so disrespectful and then
we get on Joe specifically about it but
Joe was trying to protect Tommy yeah and
they were like and one day Joe got fed
up with it he goes you know what
we're just gonna let Tommy Talk
right and so Tommy would just go start
talking and it would just be this
nonsense story and people were like oh
and he started getting ripped up in the
[__] car oh man that's sad you know
and so now Joe was like there you guys
[__] happy yeah we're trying to save
this dude's life right but they would
just rip into like his life yeah because
he would just start nonsense it's like
this fool had a stroke
Tommy would have a stroke every episode
and so people after that they started
going in on him because Tommy God man
because Tommy is not a comic you know
what I'm saying but he would try to keep
up with our energy yeah right so he
would sometimes mirror everything Joe
would say
so Joe would say something and then
Tommy would say the exact same thing
right behind him and so just to be on
the same page generally and so what
would happen was like Joe one day saying
he got fed up with it not with him but
what people were saying okay you know
what I'm not gonna say anything at all
and then Tommy would just fumble over
his words because he can't mimic Joe
anymore so then people were like oh but
then we didn't want that to happen no
that's stupid yeah it sucks what's the
point of that yeah I know but that's
during the time that we would let these
comments dictate what we would do yeah
and I didn't want I hated that stuff
because I never did that on my channel
right I just kind of said my [__] and I
took my blows if I [__] up I would
apologize for it later on in video you
know and that that was it was such a
weird time I'm so glad that that time
has now disappeared now people are kind
of sick of it it's just crazy that I I
was learning about all of this like way
later like I didn't know that you guys
were doing any of that and the funny
thing is one of the last times that I
came on as a guest when you were still
there
when when we would film and it would be
all laughing be all loud and [__] and
then once the camera Cuts between
episodes Dead Silence yeah I was like
what the [__] what the [__] going on
man
it was like nobody wants to say one word
what the [__] is this remember because
we used to shoot
starting from 9 A.M to 9pm yeah yeah
yeah it was hard we would say some crazy
[__] [__] and it would be we would be
delirious and try to say stuff for the
comedy of It kind of like you know shot
us in our shot Us in the foot because it
was delirium yeah you know like we used
to shoot a lot and it was a blessing
because everybody got paid really well
at the time because it was so successful
like like nobody talks about this stuff
but like Barton Joe
were so good to everybody yeah like yeah
yeah when things were good everybody
prospered people got bonuses every year
the month of December everybody got off
I've heard stories and it's funny
because I'm hearing it from the side of
but not anymore yeah yeah yeah yeah
because it took us to Japan yeah Board
Room stayed paid for our meals the whole
company took us to [__] Japan just
because yeah
uh took us to Vegas every [__] year
[__] Penthouse Suites geez yes
nobody talks about this stuff nah yeah
when the drama happened
I did my podcast like talking about all
the great things that they did um
because nobody wanted to defend them
dude even now it I think some people
just have a they have like this leftover
obsession with just like thinking things
are unjust there and even me like people
will directly tell me JK doesn't treat
their employees well and I'm like I'm a
[__] employee yeah I'm fine like what
are you talking about they don't know
they only hear it from like some random
[__] like dude when things were so good
we used to they used to buy us dinner at
this one spot we used to go all the time
it was a Yakitori spot right and we
could order anything and whatever and
the bill was crazy God damn man they
never gave us the limit
and we also got paid really well for
working four four to five days a month
that's the crazy thing when I heard
about you guys old schedules I was like
damn you know what I'm saying and so
like it was crazy when people were
saying like these guys are terrible
bosses I don't think you understand how
little we actually work compared to
regular people and the bonuses that we
[__] get and the other opportunities
that come because it's because Barton
Joe would also build other people's
channels for them it's like yeah go get
your [__] brand new money yeah yeah
yeah like it's kind of unreal
but I see it from that perspective
because I never forget about the hard
work that I had to do to get to where
I'm at yeah so when you work for
everything that you have you're very
appreciative sometimes when you're given
things just because like you're
ingratiated into this space yeah you
think that you are owed everything right
and it's not just with like you know
former employees it's for anybody who
does that right
yeah people never talk about like how
great of a boss they were yeah they were
flawed they made a lot they made
mistakes right when the company grew big
it was hard for them to juggle Bart had
[__] barbell Brigade you know June B
happen all these other things anything
blew up at the same time it was it was
[__] difficult you know and they were
trying their [__] best my lovely
genius farts this podcast is brought to
you by Better Health and is sponsoring
genius brains so listen up my friends if
you haven't thought about therapy maybe
you should give it a try if you're if
you're if your mind is clouded you don't
know where you're going and you only
focus on your physical health you should
focus on your mental health as well
because it's just as important if not
more important because they kind of go
in tandem for me if I work on my mental
health my physical health just works
better it just gets better man sometimes
like we're faced with tough choices and
the path board isn't always clear
whether you're dealing with decisions
around career relationships or anything
else therapy helps you stay connected to
what you really want while you navigate
life so you can move forward with
confidence and excitement so listen
trusting yourself to make decisions that
align with your values is like anything
the more you've practiced it the easier
it gets and better help can find a
therapist that can help you along with
these thoughts and these goals I
personally love better help I've been
using for a very long time now and you
guys know I'm all about that mental
health so if you're thinking about
starting therapy give better help a try
all you have to do is fill out a brief
questioner to get you matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge let
therapy be your map with Better Health
visit betterhelp.com today to get 10 off
your first month that's betterhelp
help.com genius
I think the reason why it kind of we
don't run into problems like that now is
that every person on the main cast has a
lot of [__] they're doing outside of JK
so when we come together it's like
finally we can just like it's like
breathing time yeah we come together to
do this thing and it feels like a break
from the hustle and then it's back to
the hustle like after JK's done you know
I watched that episode
um it popped up on my feet because a lot
of people were tagging me on it it was
when uh Bart and Joe talked a little bit
about the drama yeah he like addressed
it slightly yeah yeah and it was really
nice because they never said their piece
right and they still kind of have it
they haven't they just kind of said like
this is what the mission was and this is
what this was about and I really
appreciated that about them was like you
know the the mission isn't to ruin
somebody's life no right the mission is
comedy we're here to make people laugh
yeah this is what we are here for we're
gonna miss the mark sometimes not
everybody is going to laugh but
essentially this is what the goal is and
they took the high road right yeah they
did which was really really good and
it's so easy to not and you just like
buy into all that stuff because like I
mean Channel wise who wouldn't like
everybody would address that to death
yeah you know what I mean and they could
have profited off of it yeah you know
what I'm saying but that's not what this
channel is about yeah right every
company that that somebody works for if
they leave they might have some gripes
about it because it didn't work out the
way that they wanted right but I worked
for them right and I worked with them on
every [__] level yeah right but I
pulled my [__] weight and I also
worked a regular job I also worked um
even when I was doing YouTube I was
making good money I worked as a PA on
[__] film sets oh you did yeah I know
you were doing I wanted that experience
so I'm like and I worked at my parents
business I did all this other stuff so I
know what it's like to work that regular
nine to five run a bit I know what that
shit's like right to come on a channel
to build your own Fame go walk away with
the paycheck that's more than livable on
top of that get a whole month off in
December get a bonus at the end of the
year when the company did well paid
vacations food all paid for is unreal
working four to five days a week see
that's I feel like a month excuse me if
anything just that alone just the pay if
that was public would squash a lot of
people's misunderstandings yeah I feel
like because people were bringing up
other stuff too they was like oh tell us
the exact numbers that people got paid
it's like you're not privy to that
[__] information yeah no that yeah
not at all you're absolutely not and
guess what when times got tough people
didn't get paid that well we all took a
[__] cut yeah right at a certain
point like
I said this before too we were getting
paid even the days that we didn't show
up
because they would just give us a
monthly pay
jeez man yeah they don't know about that
no it was like that for years wow right
up until the point where JK was bleeding
[__] money yeah rules changed right
then it was like you're only getting
paid this amount for when you show up
but it wasn't like that for a majority
of the time until the company was going
under right but see that's what I'm
saying like why do I have to tell these
[__] details yeah I mean I'm not
saying anything because I talked to us
on a previous podcast but yeah yeah like
it was hard it was [__] hard for
everybody dude everybody took such a
[__] hard hit dude they don't even
know Bart and Joe weren't even taking a
[__] check in the first few few like
few years of JK I honestly don't even
know if they're taking anything now now
I do the math in my head sometimes I'm
like you guys have no way [__] I was
like there's no way how are you doing
that well that's what I'm saying like
and nobody should have to say this like
I shouldn't have to come out and say
this yeah right because honestly it's
none of your [__] business and we
like to keep things in the family right
I do want people to understand that
these are some of the best people I've
ever known in my life yeah we've opened
businesses together we have a matcha
franchise together I have made many of
plenty of mistakes they have forgiven my
mistakes and we've I've gotten better
because of them yeah right because I've
owned up to my mistakes whenever I
showed up like I forgot to mention
something that I had to do they've
always were very gracious make it work
yeah they made it work and I was not the
I wasn't the most perfect one of the
group like I would [__] up I would say
some crazy [__] that I wasn't and you
know were at the time it was like the
wokes and times I would [__] up and they
gave me Grace I have never ever worked
at a place that was like that I don't
think you can find a place like that
anymore at all yeah at [__] I think
by law they can't exist
would have to go under
dude Bart and Joe did such they did
their best and when things got so out of
hand when the company was bleeding money
and everybody was hurting they you know
people don't talk about what they were
going through yeah it's hard to watch
your brainchild [__] die in front of
you
you know imagine how [__] difficult
that [__] is yeah right and every time I
had a conversation with Joe he's like
[__] like how am I gonna get these guys
paid he wasn't even talking about
himself but you blew my [__] mind you
know they're not gonna go ahead and say
that and it's such a long-running uh
it's like JK news isn't some like random
thing that popped up for like two years
and then now they can't sustain it that
shit's like kind of part of everything
it's like part of the history yeah of
just like Asian YouTube in general yeah
people who have left JK are doing fine
on their own they're very successful
that's what I was saying I'm like when I
look at that I'm like everybody looks
like they're okay they're doing great
yeah you know what I mean and that's not
in spite of Jake it's because of right
and nobody's going out of the way to
like watching other people succeed makes
us very [__] happy yeah it it really
makes me feel so that's the one thing
that when I visited you guys on at the
new studio and I think I went into
either it was maybe your office or
somebody's and I saw on the wall there
was like a list of companies that you
guys were all affiliated with me and
dietrichs were there together for JK
party and then I remember like I was
like talking to D and I was like dude
these dudes are like they're
they're Asian but they're doing like
white people [__] like they're doing as
the whites do yeah yeah yeah yeah
they're owning companies like like in a
row like there were so many different
affiliations I'm like we've we've always
worked very hard to just do our thing
very well like whatever our one thing is
but then I've never seen the example of
another like you know we were all in
this Alliance of Asian creators
independent companies whatever but I've
never seen it Diversified to that level
yeah and it was like inspiring to me I'm
like damn success by yourself is very
[__] lonely yeah like being
successful with others is probably one
of the best feelings I've ever had in my
life like growing with my friends
watching everybody have kids own their
first homes like building like me and
Joe opening a store up in Waikiki
together like these moments are the
moments that I cherish the most because
imagine like having money and success by
yourself on nobody else is to partake in
this yeah you just become that guy
that's like oh I'm gonna go here sorry I
have to work that's kind of what I felt
like happened to Victor I feel like he
tried so hard to be successful and then
kind of alienated other people out of
his life to reach the top and once he
was there he was like
anybody happy for me or what's up yeah
yeah yeah like no one was around anymore
that's a tragic story for a lot of
people yeah and they go oh these friends
are fake it's like no man like
sometimes it's you forgetting where you
came from yeah yeah yeah yeah like
watching Everybody succeed dude Bart Joe
they were so [__] broke when I met
them like I remember because Bart had to
live in his parents house like the
rental spot yeah and then Joe lived in
the back house right and then Bart's mom
in order for him to save up money
wouldn't charge him rent so he had he
got to live there for free and then
everybody else was taking a paycheck
from JK and they weren't and I was the
one who had the most money right because
I had my own channel my own thing and I
was making money yeah yeah but then by
the way when I say I was the richest one
I was still poor as [__] yeah it's not
saying that yeah yeah exactly so we were
the least poor yeah I'm the least poor
Adam all you [__] dude that's right
dude I got the most gas in my tank [__]
but those are the memories that we
cherish a lot because we got to kind of
suffer together and a lot of the people
that ended up not staying with us or the
people that didn't get to suffer with us
right that didn't struggle with us at
the time yeah and so for us we always
have this eye of like graciousness and
we always talks like hey remember that
time when we had to [__] split this
or we had to split that and you know I I
cherish those moments the most it was
the most exciting because I like I'll
never trade those memories for anything
right I've known Bart and Joe now for
for a decade plus I've never had a
single problem with any of them
right they've allowed me to be who I am
I allow them to be who they are and
we're imperfect creatures that that are
just learning and getting better till
this day and like I you can't get
friendship like that dude it's crazy and
and we're living in a place where it's
common to just not have long friendships
yeah like everybody's mad like fast like
besties overnight and then no longer
talking bro I've had the same precious
Elementary School yeah like I I says a
lot it says a lot to have long ass
friends I I've never I just don't throw
away people like that because even like
people now who we I don't talk as much
but they play such an important part of
my life when I was younger if they need
me I'm there yeah right like these
people who've built you up literally
invested into you maybe not financially
but they invest into you some type of
way that allowed you to do what you do
next right yeah it's hard for me to just
throw away people so one of the things
too that I'll always say and I never
talk big about myself I may not be the
most I'm dumb as [__] but I know how to
make friends and
I know something about friendships and
decent [__] human beings yeah right
because if you're telling me right now
then you know more about French is that
me then I better hope that you've had
the same friend since you were two years
old because I have about [__] 10 of
them like that
and these [__] are still my friends
till this [__] day I never realized
because like that's normal to us right
like it's normal to have friends for
that long but then you realize later
that's not it's not something you can
find everywhere A lot of people now are
very opportunistic yeah so they look at
people as opportunities rather than
connections yeah dude especially you
working in entertainment that's most of
the people you're gonna meet yeah
they're gonna see you that way yeah hey
man I [__] that's my bro you just met
him
yeah I don't know him you can always
tell it when someone's introducing you
to someone else and how they talk about
you and you know they don't know you
that well and they're like yo anything
you need this guy is the man like he's
like really anything like bro anything
I'm a little horny
finish me off right now bro make it
happen I'm very wary about people who
kind of immediately say oh that's my bro
that's my homie I am not your bro or
your homie yeah we got drunk once and I
drank an oyster shooter out of your
belly button
there are also people that have an odd
low threshold for killing someone for
you yeah they're like yo I will [__]
[__] someone up for you bro and they
just met you yesterday it's like there
are crazy ass people like that too
you're like why do you have my back so
hard bro it's like you'll do that for me
too right absolutely not
absolutely not somebody's [__] with
you you're just gonna get your ass beat
yeah and I'm just gonna [__] world
star that [__] I don't know like what
what that's a product of but yeah some
people are your friend for real to an
uncomfortable quick degree dude and then
but those people too who like quick
friend you they also get disappointed
and you're super fast yeah that's true
the expectations like yeah astronomical
I didn't know like that's not you man
you don't know me
I have that I am exactly that you're
just disappointed they're like oh man
what happened to David dude it's like
nothing I'm the same [__] guy man
yeah I I cut that [__] off real fast now
it's like dude it's like dude that's my
[__] boy I am not your boy
it's hard man friendships are hard to
navigate in [__] California in
general I feel like you have such a
strong group of friends though I think I
was lucky to find a lot of people that
have that same Vibe you know but that's
just like JK that's why like we all
resonated together that generation in
general of Asian independent creators
had a very similar idea of like what
they wanted out of like person-to-person
friendships I feel like yeah and like I
think we also kind of have we're our
generation is very unique because I
think that we can all appreciate other
people without having to really
necessarily like everything that they do
yeah absolutely yeah right like I said
on this podcast like I [__]
appreciate the [__] out of Wong Fu I
don't like a lot of their stuff
you know like that's because I'm such a
piece of [__] and they're so kind yeah
you know I know I get it yeah like
there's no way that I'm going to watch
um [__] you know strangers forever
and ever and then [__] relate to that
[__] I'm not yeah I'm gonna watch but
it's like thank God it exists exactly
and it's there for people yeah thank God
that people relate to this stuff and I'm
pretty sure that people have these
emotions but for me it's not gonna
resonate yeah there's a lot of stuff
that they make that I do like right but
people never understood that concept
like I talked about this and people like
why are you hating on them I'm like I
know them what are you talking about why
are you suppressing them bro yeah like
what the [__] are you talking like you
know me now like how am I supposed to
relate to that [__] yeah yeah yeah I'm
not gonna [__] relate to it it's not
going to make sense yeah you know what
I'm saying like I remember I did a
parody of their stuff
and like people were like damn you
roasted them I'm like I'm not roasting
them man David hates me yeah I can't do
anything
he wants them to die people thought I
[__] hated Ryan Higa why because they
asked if I if I found him stuff funny
and I was like nah it's not my thing
like I don't think his stuff is very
funny but he's like one of my favorite
creators yeah but they just delete
completely deleted that last part
you know like till this day I'm sad that
he doesn't make YouTube videos anymore
literally one of the best creators that
have ever existed on the space
absolutely yeah so I didn't enjoy all of
his stuff because we have a different
sense of humor he is the goat to me and
it's like you don't want him to change
his humor to fit yours you know what I
mean it's like don't start making [__]
that I like make what you make exactly
so but are you used to that like were
you always like that as a kid that you
were like oh half the class is gonna
hate me I think
every class you go to hey man I got used
to people [__] hating me man
um and you know honestly it was like me
trying to be a stand-up comic and it was
some really good advice from a stand-up
comic
um at the time who came he goes you know
when you do stand-up comedy you got to
stop doing this thing where he would see
that I would do this where you're trying
not to offend people oh he goes go up
there say how you [__] feel and take
the shots like say what you say what you
want for the [__] joke yeah you know
what I'm saying right stop being on the
fence and that's what a lot of comics do
now oh but if you do this it's like dog
that's hard just stick to the joke you
know people who get offended they will
get offended just try to make your stuff
clever and funny and I would do that so
often so I just got used to just taking
whatever would come you know I think
that's also why like auditioning at
first for roles used to [__] me up for
the first two auditions or so and then
it kind of got scabbed over yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's kind of how you have to
be yeah because like look if you do
stand up even till this day stand up is
frightening for me when I go up on stage
and I do my stand a bit and even though
I've been doing it since I was 16 I
still feel that still scary [__]
scary gut in my feeling it's like dude
you have to prove to this group of like
a hundred or [__] 50 people that
you're [__] funny that don't know who
you are yeah and it and they're not even
primed to laugh like they're sitting
there like this yeah and you gotta
somehow make them [__] laugh yeah
when you're in an audition room it's
just like two people that you just have
to prove that you can act
it's okay I'll [__] live yeah you go
up on stage nobody laughs it's one of
the worst feelings on Earth
do you lit I literally want to die I
don't think I could ever get myself to
do that try it so you could feel my pain
[__] man like it's I [__] you not it is
painful you know what you know why I
believe that so much because every
comedian no matter where they are in
their career still admits that bombing
is the worst feeling on Earth it hurts
so bad it hurts so bad like um I can't
remember the last time I bombed big
right but when I did Bob this one time
was I was performing at a bar TVs were
playing and I wanted all these noise and
[__] dude I went up to do my set not a
single person left and I was like this
is the day that I end myself
I just and luckily one of my homies who
is a really good comic at the time yeah
came up and he started roasting the
crowd for me for being [__] and he
made a funny sound after your set yeah
and then he was killing it oh of course
but like I thanked him so much I was
like bro you made me feel better he goes
bro that crowd was terrible you didn't
address your own bombing while it was
happening no I just started fumbling
over my words okay please laugh do you
remember the context of anything you
said no I don't it was such a blur I
remember my face turning red and just
like please somebody laugh at anything I
swear so like people were paying
attention to you they just weren't
laughing it wasn't that they were
distracted they were distracted and they
were drunk I did another performance it
was actually at a b-boy jam and they
wanted a stand-up comic thing in Sac and
I said yes to it and it was terrible bro
b-boy Champion what were your jokes I
don't even remember bro it was so
[__] you don't beat my jokes hey what
do you call a dude who does a [__]
pose and his ass crack is showing a
hollow crap back
hey that dude's funny
dog hey that's not the only crickets in
the crowd
I don't think any like anything that's
happening at a jam that's not b-boyant
it doesn't work like they've tried
everything like spoken word they'll do
like I was dating a Filipino girl all
the time and she came to the show and
she saw me bomb I was so funny she
actually gave me head out of pity I
think that day
she's just giving you a pat on the back
wall sucking yeah she's like it's okay
she could feel the tears hit the back of
her head
dog it was so [__] sad there was
actually a beat boy what the [__] was
his name and I really liked him a lot
but he laughed at some of my jokes and
remedy it wasn't it wasn't a remedy
a sack B boy yeah uh no it was um
[__] nasty Ray oh yeah well he's a
funny guy so he would get it nasty Ray
laughed at some of my jokes and I was
like you know I'm a big fan of his
because nasty where he's [__] yeah so
like nasty actually laughed at some of
my jokes I was like thanks man
being the one guy thanks for being the
one guy that stopped actually last
well everybody else is [__] trying to
get their [__] you know set ready
together and [__] like that and I'm
almost dude yeah hey guys you know what
it's like being a Korean guy
that's hard to do with stand-up comedy
act that's like I want to die right now
and that happened [__] like 15 years
ago
and it still kills you you're like still
[__] kills me man I maybe the part of
that is because you'll never have like a
retribution for that specific moment
like you'll never go back to that exact
time and do a good job dude there's
something that stands as a bad thing
I've said that I don't think I ever said
that like so sometimes I think about
like dude I wish I could sometimes go
back in time yeah and then re-fuck the
girls that I get terrible [__] dick
too
there's no point just stop just don't do
it hey bro you're not good dude who are
you spare her this memory yeah yeah I I
just want to go back in times like I can
do better yeah
I could do so much
watch my tongue
watch it's way worse yeah it's like way
worse she goes oh my God that was
[__] trash like I just get so
embarrassed like it I don't ever regret
anything right but then going back to
those memories of just going on stage
and not hearing a single laugh it's
[__] terrifying oh my God yeah isn't
that great that when you guys were doing
JK all the time there wasn't live
reactions to like everything you said oh
my God you could hear audibly like in
here dude that would be torturing his
life would kill oh when you guys would
go and do it at places they've never
done it never did it would smash never
done it you guys never but wasn't there
times you did to like uh conventions or
[__] like that we would do I would do
college shows but I'll just do stand up
by myself oh yeah so I would work these
sets and do stand-up and stuff like that
I would really love for them to do JK
News live do JK live I mean you would
have to set it up where it's a very
entertaining show where you keep the
crowd involved like a game show yeah
yeah you just have to set that up right
that [__] would [__] smash just no
budget for it yeah somehow we have to do
it without it can't afford it yeah we're
gonna have to do it one of the things
that people want I'm gonna do a genius
brain like comedy thing yeah like
where's the stand up with all the
stand-up comments who came on here and
then we're gonna do our own sets
but I I'm like I've thought about this
right now or I'm just gonna have an open
event and there's gonna be no cover
charge
um it's donations only whoa you pay what
you feel like you want because I don't
want to gatekeep it with money like like
I'm not doing it for a paycheck anyways
and my friends just want to do it to
work their sets and have a longer set
than five minutes that's really cool and
I'm like hey you guys pay what you want
like if you find Value in this
um and you only have a dollar 30 Cent
pay Palo 30 cents pay a dollar I don't
give a [__] just come here and enjoy so
I I'm gonna do it on a donation basis so
I want to set that up uh probably like
in August and I honestly I won't do long
sets it's just gonna be like a 10-15
minute set and somebody else will do
another 15 another 15 another 15. that's
dope and people come out and enjoy
themselves yeah and then Ryan you're
going to be the headliner dude I'm the
headliner yep yeah and then I'm gonna
make you break your [__] ACL again
I'll just do ministry for 70 hours
[Laughter]
if like friends with funny like even if
you didn't do stand up and they know you
like try a five minute set and it's a
it's a crowd that people know you and if
you suck at it you know what you know
what that is it like I equate that in my
mind to like hey you kind of looked cool
dancing for a second do a five minute
show like the idea of that
the stand-up is the most disrespected
profession on Earth yeah
everybody's like oh you can do stand up
it's the worst like when when like a
friend or like a homework comes up to
another girl and she's like you know
what you're [__] fine that's a
different that's a different situation
man and girls do that to each other
that's really dangerous they just gassed
them up have you here
you can try doing gang it and they go up
and they it's the worst thing ever
that's the hardest thing man like at
least guys are more like prone to just
be dicks to each other and tell each
other they suck but like when women are
empowering each other for [__] that's
like you don't even you're funny they
just don't know you're funny
no don't do that that's dangerous dude
my buddy Tyler one of the funniest dudes
you'll ever meet in your life right just
sitting around a circle like talking
[__] like this has me crying laughing
yeah and then I was like
you should do stand up right and I
really thought he'd be great he goes up
boss goes up again bombs bombs so now he
has the worst core memories ever I know
and I was like [__] I felt so bad but
I'm like
bro you're so [__] funny like just
say what you said to us on stage yeah
don't do the other [__] tip it was
like weird typical jokes that people
ever I'm like tell that story of when
you were [__] your wife in the ass
and it was so [__] funny just do that
you know what it is it's like like if I
was to do that right I don't think I
have the patience because you know the
patience of not hearing the crowd react
and it's okay I don't have that built in
oh yeah because even when I'm dancing I
don't have that patience like if I'm
doing like a set like a dance set and I
haven't done anything that made someone
audibly go oh then I feel like I'm doing
a bad job yeah so I think when you know
where you're going in comedy like with
your with your comedic set you can
understand to ride the pocket I'm not
gonna have that so I'm gonna get nervous
and start doing some cheap ass things I
think are funny and people do the same
thing as stand-up I used to do that too
it's exactly like stand up yeah is that
is that similar one of the things that I
used to do that I [__] hated in
myself that I don't do now
is that I would always do these cheap
stupid monikers of like doing an accent
just because it would get white people
to laugh
but isn't that the age-old like that's
the Temptation right exactly because I
know it's going to get an instant laugh
yeah and I'm like you know what dude
nah like you're gonna have to sit there
and if you bomb just take it just sit
there and finish your joke and work that
[__] set because now my stand-up is
more myself I would use I used to just
like say these one-off like stupid jokes
but now I'm more into like okay say what
you feel build your idea yeah right and
do what you do and I started becoming
better at that yeah and then when I
understood that look it's okay for to
build up a story you be I became better
at it like don't freak out don't do it
don't go up there go do man like [__]
don't say it don't say it
just [__] ride the pocket out and say
your joke dude even doing a set where
that's what you're saying is pretty
[__] funny
like that's the hard part about stand up
too and by the way sometimes your sets
will hit sometimes it won't yeah right
and I've seen people now who like
they they're trying to make this set
work and I've seen it at a club where it
made somebody cry laughing yeah yeah and
the next club that they did that I went
with them and it's verbatim the exact
same delivery everything yeah nobody
[__] laughs so you just gotta figure
that [__] out and you have to be okay
with it man and it's [__] hard it's
like I'm sitting there telling this set
I'm like no it's gonna kill and then you
just hear
I'm like oh god oh man hi everybody see
that's that's like oh God that's that's
the thing where like being a dancer is
like meh a million times easier because
you just finish your [__] you don't have
to deal with like or do people like it
it's like you're just doing your thing
dude dance I remember because I was such
a huge yeah everybody dances in
Sacramento right even I tried doing it I
couldn't dance I couldn't dance and I
went straight to [__] singing and I
went straight to [__] doing comedy
I'm like this is not my thing right I
cannot do this there's so many freaking
crews in Zach dude so many dude hell
among [__] Crews oh yeah yeah yeah
Mom people are gang banging they were
b-boying the [__] out of people dude
thank thank thank God for b-boying for
like some of these monkeys man they
saved them they don't know anything else
yeah dude you want to talk about [__]
during the height of [__] like air
power right Hmong dudes they were the
first ones to grab air flares there's
nothing yeah air steps and like crazy
like how the [__] are these you know
what because their body is so short and
they got some they got some big dudes
that are flying what's that
this boy dog he defies the laws of
physics exactly it's crazy yeah it
doesn't make it's dummy it's [__]
crazy it doesn't make sense like I I
just remember just like
during the time like Sacramento was so
good with dance like there's so many
like it has a huge art culture exactly
great art culture yeah so like watching
all like b-boy Morris right from
Sacramento this guy is [__] killing
it freestyle killing it still [__]
killing it right and like like watching
these guys go to such a bigger platform
was [__] nuts yeah [__] a Phil
tayak also from [__] Sacramento right
for one of the founding members of
[__] Jabberwockies the stereotypes
World we're now producers [__] John
yip right uh Jeremy like germs German B
they're from Sacramento stereotypes man
I didn't even know they were from Sac
for so long yeah man they're [__]
Sacramento people dude uh Victor Kim
also from Sacramento yeah all these
people came from Sacramento and people
don't even know about it yeah so like
like Phil tayak like I remember watching
Phil as a freshman
um at foreign high school and he would
perform
uh at our assemblies because we had like
the high school dance team and what he
was doing was so [__] mind-blowing at
the time right because he also had
Boogie monsters right so Boogie monsters
like the way that they were doing things
were so [__] different super
different yeah and at the time like I
remember what blew people's mind was
like watching people do set choreography
that they thought that you couldn't do
as a set because people wouldn't be able
to follow it so people would dumb down
the set so it would be very easy choreo
but the boogie monster was like nah you
can follow this yeah right and so
watching people do these very like
difficult moves that they thought only
you could do as a solo but doing it in a
group was wild it always like blew my
mind that so many Innovations were based
in Sac like of all the places in the
world like whole dance forms just came
out of sack yeah it's like so weird hey
do you know about Black Flag dance yeah
Black Flag is [__] is the now of all
that [__] you listed like they are the
today yeah of all of that like it was so
uh [__] your boy uh Rudy raynon also
from Sam yeah Rue yeah yeah I mean like
Rudy's [__] sick as hell dude and you
know not only as a [__] musician as a
[__] dancer he does tricks yep uh is
I thought Rudy was actually related to
like the Filipino kid in uh Black Flag
Ren yeah Ren Chris they're not related
right I don't know I'm not sure I
thought that was like his nephew or some
[__] like that maybe I wouldn't be
surprised if I mean they're Filipino and
they're in Sac somebody somewhere linked
it up that feels [__] sick as hell
dude you have people like TJ Lewis also
part of the job TJ Lewis I remember TJ
when he was a little [__] kid yeah
you know I mean I have videos of TJ
Lewis I have videos of TJ uh [__] uh
what's it called they were the trio at
the time it was the two Filipino kids
who are now Jabba walking members and
the one the kid Kita Kita oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so those two are
Jabberwockies and then obviously key to
the great did his own [__] thing or
America's Got Talent pull him up and he
did his own thing they were a trio at
the time and I have videos of them when
they were like [__] seven or eight
years old damn dude yeah that's the
crazy thing about the sack scene it's
like they they really honed in on us on
a particular form yeah if you guys don't
know who TJ Lewis is like follow him
like he is to me one of the best dancers
to ever come out of Sacramento yeah he
is like the future to me like I think he
could dust anybody out there he's that
[__] DJ's crazy yo he's nuts like
when I see him move I'm like dude I
remember this kid was a little [__]
kid and now he's a grown ass [__] man
just dancing his [__] heart out yeah
and didn't they do something in Sac
where they like they put funds towards
like the Art District so that like
artists could live and like and work on
their craft and not have to deal with
like rent yeah they still have that
there he is dope as [__] you have to be
our artist to live there and you have to
make a certain amount of income to be
able to live there or not make a certain
amount of income right right there's
like a window you have to fit inside and
you have to be practicing your work like
to a degree where it shows progress or
something the area's so [__] done we
have like so much street art out there
yeah Sacramento is a really dope City if
you want to go towards like the artist
side because it would you know people
really develop that side a lot yeah so I
we've been able I've been very fortunate
to see other people do it before me to
make me want to do it like it's kind of
crazy like being able to meet up and
Link with Phil and be like [__] man you
were like my neighbor we used to play
basketball together yeah you know and
now people people look at him as like a
Godfather that's what's crazy why like I
can't believe I missed you so many times
yeah don't skip away from each other
because like I mean did you because I
was living with Victor for years yeah
and we never went dude I knew like like
D-Trix too also from Sacramento yeah
yeah yeah you know what I'm saying like
D-Trix
I haven't seen that for [__] ages man
yeah he was the person that told me that
when when we were watching your [__] Dee
was like yo you know he's from sag and
he's like friends with Victor and I went
how the [__] are we not met him dude he
he had a video that had me crying
laughing like an old one or no when he
[__] showed his bald head oh bro bro
dude I was literally crying from
laughing because I'm like dude this guy
is ridiculous I'm so proud of him for
that [__] he did that sneeze and his
head came off the front I [__]
dropped everything he was he cracked me
the [__] up I was so proud for that
because like he had been losing hair for
years those head spins dude and we like
we had to like because I was cutting his
hair all those years and we like made
this style where the these parts were
long and it went in like a ship to cover
like the receding wow and like you know
it just it just kept getting further and
further back and then he was like I
gotta find man so then like I looked up
like how what are some systems that you
can get to like fix this and then we
went to that spot and he was like come
with me let's record it just in case
someday I want to reveal that I'm bald
yeah and so we went we recorded the
whole thing we laughing our asses off
like it's a very serious Place yeah
you're not supposed to make jokes out of
the whole [__] and then he came up with
this freaking genius idea like he talked
to the owner and was like
check this out everybody that comes
through here has to keep it a secret
that they're coming here he goes I don't
I could tell my fan base on ball yeah
and then so he did this deal where he
like
um they worked with him in exchange for
publicizing that he got it that's
amazing yeah and he was like the first
guy out of that whole like office to
have ever you know brought PR in I was
actually shocked because of how good it
looked yeah it's really it's convincing
if he never said anything nobody would
have known I don't think so it looks so
[__] good and you know what's funny
there's a lot of people that got their
stuff done at the same place
and you'll never know they have it
either guys
I think now is the time if I did if that
did happen I would just tell people like
I don't give a [__] yeah is what it is
yeah I mean right like if I honestly if
I went bald like around the time well I
I was talking to
a doctor they're like well Bill powder
and baldness wants you at your mid
Thursday and if you still have your hair
most likely you'll keep it till you're
like at least your 50s I've heard that
yeah yeah so I was like okay that's like
the threshold it's like if it's gone at
that point you're pretty much done say
bye-bye yeah so when I still had my hair
and he was like you're fine like your
hair's I have thin hair but you're not
balding you've always had thin hair so
just don't worry about maybe in your 50s
you might start balding but in my 50s I
Don't Give a [__] Yeah Yeah by then and
people just don't give a [__] either
exactly my [__] balls are at my
ankles who cares
I don't give a [__] no one's even
looking at you let alone making fun of
you I know like can you pick your balls
off the floor please it's [__]
disgusting are those yours okay thank
you that's so warm
dude man losing hair is like a it's a
crazy thing too especially for for Dom
because like hair was a part of his
brand yeah so at first like I was even I
was like oh what the [__] gonna happen
you know I couldn't like definitely if I
went bald you would see me so buff
I'm not I'm not I'm not good looking
enough for that [__] dude there's so
many Buddha jokes that could happen I
can't be fat and look like this Asian
and bald I have to get buffed right
right I have no choice I'm taking
steroids I'm doing everything yeah yeah
yeah so like if I still have hair I'm
still gonna be like this once the hair
goes bro I'm gonna be [__] jacked you
know what that is a nice reconciliation
because when you're jacked and bald
nobody even notices and it just looks
good yeah it's like that's what it's
supposed to be yeah I can't I can't feel
you look like the Kung Fu Hustle old guy
that like comes out
and they're like that is tight that's
why Detroit's got fat he got the hair
piece yeah he just went ball doesn't
[__] matter now yeah that's [__]
matter I'm beautiful look at this
[__] beautiful hair piece dude those
hair pieces are crazy too they're so
expensive how much do they cost I don't
well I think if you go through like an
agency they just hike it up like crazy
those are essentially just [__] from
China you could probably get on T on
Teemu yeah but like that [__] is like uh
there's thousands of dollars sometimes
yeah depending yeah holy [__] but again
like I think if you're just kind of
jumping into it without any knowledge
you kind of go yeah of course they are
but then they're not they're like pretty
cheap if you get it if you cut out the
the 50 middle men you takes to get it
yeah I mean you get the piece and then
you could use that and then that process
would probably go like 100 bucks every
time yeah and it really is just like you
shave your whole head and you keep the
sides and then you just put the glue and
you just stick it down it's a whole
process how long does it last I think
typically like if you're not sweating a
whole lot I think it lasts like a month
or so damn as long as [__] it could be
wrong but like I know for like Dom he
had to change it more because like he
was he was active yeah yeah yeah so but
it's one of those things where you
really can't do anything you can swim
you can do whatever like it's
undetectable Bro [__] like that's just
crazy oh my I might just get rid of the
[__] on my head right now and do it I
feel like a lot of people actually do
that too because it's like fat like you
know those China tick tocks or the dudes
have been switching them and [__] yeah
it's like that it's so quick to just put
on a new hairstyle damn that picture
just blew my [__] mind now I'm like I
don't feel so bad like when I'm I don't
know I'm fine now but like if I had to
deal with that yeah I definitely would
have called Dom up I was like hey bro
show me the ways yeah yeah you got one
time like years ago before we had his
body up and tell the story where okay
Dom hit me up and he so there was this
girl she was a YouTuber at the time
named Gabby Hannah yeah yeah and then I
I didn't do this video as an attack
piece it was a video of me and Justin in
a car we're just talking about random
[__] oh and it was about her stealing
like Bill Burr bits oh you know what I'm
saying I was like I remember that era
yeah there was like a Louis C.K
discrepancy yeah
That's how little I care
and then dude
you know Dom was good friends with her
yeah yeah so Dom she she was venting to
Dom about me about oh because like she
had assumed you were connected yeah he's
like what the [__] this fat [__] is
talking [__] about me but all this other
stuff saying all this mean [__]
terrible [__] yeah I'm like about what
you know oh she's mad because of that
video I'm like well I thought isn't it
pretty you did steal it like it's not a
you know just apologize to move on is
that a problem you know but for her it's
a big [__] deal she's also a lot
younger than
because I didn't say she wasn't talented
I didn't say she wasn't a she's she's
actually really talented yeah she
actually is yeah very [__] talented
insane yeah you cannot take that away
from her she really is and so he he hits
me up hey bro like
I'm not telling you to put the video
down because she's asking I'm I just
have to tell you because she asked me to
tell you but don't take the video down
I'm so dumb it's such a nice thing to do
out of friendship I have to tell you
right out of his duty as a homie yeah he
has to yeah but as a homie you shouldn't
take the video but as a person of Comedy
yeah of course I'm not gonna take it
down right I don't give a [__] yeah and
that's the last you heard of that that's
the last that I heard of that I was just
like why you hate me so much it's funny
too because I felt like there was if she
was going around trying to address
everyone that was making content about
that that must have been a really long
job
yeah at the time I was just seeing it
everywhere like this whole like thing
because I felt like in a way she to be
fair it's like yeah that happened but
also I think a lot of people were using
it as a way to pit uh traditional comedy
against YouTubers or against content
creators where they were like see
everyone does it look at this example
you know like it was a good it was a
good entry point to start the
conversation of like no one is original
on Vine yeah you know it was like a good
so I think yeah stealing content now is
so weird because now we have you know I
always say this like tick tocker is for
the person who who has absolutely no
talent that wants to pretend like they
have it right and that's not really a
dis it's what Tick Tock was created for
right you yeah you talk to these people
it's like no we put things in this app
so the non-creative person can be it's
for everyone to participate exactly like
you could be the that's why you'll see
the the same joke everybody does the
same joke doesn't do anything different
yeah don't change any of it you're right
and they love they love it they go like
Oh They'll do like uh I don't know a
couple's joke that one couple did that
blew up and then you see another couple
do the same joke yep I'm like what the
[__] is this and then people are all
okay with it and we're the odd ones out
for thinking there's a problem with that
yeah so you stole that [__] yeah it's
like no that's the point like everyone's
here to participate in the same activity
like I I don't understand why that's so
LAX but I guess it's because it's that
culture now I think so too yeah it is
that culture I personally don't like
that like no yeah let people have that
joke that was their joke I think we
heavily misunderstood it as dancers too
me and Dom went through it a little bit
because we started seeing all these kids
taking quests made moves and like using
them in their tick tocks or whatever and
then you know not crediting or whatever
yeah yeah and then it came down to a
point where like uh like Dom had
facetimed one of those creators to just
tell him like Hey I'm just here to teach
you that in dance that's not something
you do you just don't take signature
moves and then repurpose them without
giving credit and these kids were like
pretty receptive they were like oh okay
okay I get it I get it and these kids
like I'm not gonna name because I'm
gonna put them out but they're the top
yeah and they were really really
respectful and cool next day just kept
on doing it of course they just did went
back and did the same [__] and they
never stopped stealing dance moves and
and put them up and it was like so it's
literally the place for non-creators to
prevent him like they're creative yeah
and it's it's weird like how do you
really it like even on this podcast I
get scared of sharing story because I
know it's gonna end up in somebody
else's script sure it happens like it
happened to dumb and dumb was okay with
it like like I guess I'm not trying to
throw [__] but he had like the writer of
beef on there he goes oh actually there
was a joke in beef that I got from your
podcast it was about recognizing the
back of age Asian people's heads I got
it from this podcast and then was like
yeah he said that's dope that's dope
that's from us I'm like no that's not
dope he stole your [__]
I put it in a script is that
but the double like I said dumb's fine
with it for me it feels weird like I
said like I feel like I'm not a part of
these times because if somebody
blatantly told me that look you
took a a bit of mine and then you just
put blatantly put it into here and
that's for traditional media yeah it's
for traditional so isn't there a little
bit more of a that's what I'm saying I
don't know because I would I would
understand if it was for short form
whatever because no one gives a [__]
they just make stuff it's about get
making it now but then traditional media
there's at least a bridge that they can
cross and go hello dumb like yeah hey
it's like dude I like a lot of the bits
in your podcast like I want to use that
in this script is that cool like can we
exchange whatever and that's the thing
that happens so what happened there like
I honestly you would look at that stuff
too and there's a lot like obviously
there's parallels that people have in
like a lot of lives because it's very
Asian American Great American but I
think I'm pretty not surprised that they
stole from a lot of people's like Asian
American podcast so like watching that
type of stuff like him openly say that
like it's cool I'm like that's actually
not cool in my opinion but
like and beef was great like beef was a
[__] amazing Series so like hearing
that was disappointing for me it's like
you're a writer bro wouldn't you hate it
if somebody did that to you you're a
[__] writer man yeah you know but
like I said I still enjoy the show it
doesn't change that I just thought it
was really weird I I think it's weird
when it's the same Community I don't
think it's as weird if it's on [__]
you know some white show yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah then I'm like yeah of course
because they're drawing from all these
like they're researching for this [__]
but then if it's that doesn't seem like
it's too many degrees away to just give
a heads up yeah at least to me I don't
know yeah I don't know what if I'd even
walk credits like yo thanks for the
heads up because it would suck for me
yeah the respect it just feels like the
respect was not there but I actually saw
the onslaught of people being okay with
stealing content so anybody can be
famous was when I I did this there was
this kid who was blatantly taking my
YouTube
um Vlogs where I would just talk [__]
the camera yeah and it's using it as
stand-up sets which pissed me off oh
because whoa those YouTube rant Vlogs
were it was just bad stand-up that I
would repurpose and put into Vlogs and
then he would go up on stage and then
bomb with it I'm like don't you dare use
my bad stand up it's a misrepresentation
of me it's only funny in video forms and
so he would still bombing with your [__]
yeah I'm like you do it right
you know that's even funnier that it
didn't go well exactly I am way funnier
than that but I literally like put this
kid on blast I'm like you're stealing my
[__] and then like there was at the time
like 20 of people was like what's the
problem if it makes people laugh I'm
like
see that's the generation though that's
that's the Gap and again like you kind
of you had to work hard for this yeah it
took me time to figure out how to make
this [__] funny I you weren't up
there like on set with me getting
bombing on stage to figure out what
could make people laugh yeah you weren't
out there [__] doing like trying to
figure out like my style and dance and
everything else to figure out what makes
this work like you didn't have to go
through all that other stuff yeah you
get to take it like that and say it's
yours you know what's the difference
with that [__] which which like really
it hit me pretty hard to realize this is
that we don't tend to as old-fashioned
creators feel you know we don't exploit
our own material
um and the way that I realize that is
that if if a tick tocker thought of a
move you will see a million videos of
that one move yeah but then in our day
it was like that was just one of your
Arsenal and it came out when the timing
is right but you didn't exploit the [__]
out of your own thing like and I think
when they look at you think of something
and you didn't exploit it they're like
well then you're not gonna use it why
don't you use it yeah exactly it's that
and it's hard to argue with that
rationale because you're like yeah
you're right I am just gonna kind of
keep it here and not do anything with it
yeah yeah yeah yeah so then they look at
it like well then you're doing something
dumb because you could be making money
you know and I also understand too like
Phil too is it's very specific about
[__] biting right literally Boogie
monsters biters will be [__] that's
like their [__] That's The Credo
exactly right right and so you know even
like Phil like he had like another
pop-off moment where he created this
move called the SackBoy and also you see
everybody doing it you know what I'm
saying I'm like the [__] is that [__]
about and then for him I think it's a
point of Pride he's like hey that's mine
like and like I'm not making money off
of this [__] so at least like have
people know where it came from right you
know and he's an innovator he's a
[__] innovator he's like a genius
innovator so it's like it would I
understand it's like if I'm not gonna
get paid for this at least like this is
my stamp and my legacy about something I
[__] love yeah yeah that's another
thing that's hard it's like it it is
difficult to find out where that lies
because it's such a gray area because
we're also as dancers we're using [__]
that we don't know the the basis to
where it all came from either like
there's a lot of [__] that the proper
credit can't be found sometimes yeah
yeah yeah yeah so even when I made this
like uh this real and I said leche
duffels right that's from [__]
theovan and people were crying like
that's so [__] hilarious but in the
caption I wrote yeah right right because
it's not my joke and I know people are
gonna laugh at it it's not something
that I said I know it's Theo Von's thing
yeah right so I feel weird about that
sometimes and I even got called out
before years ago they're like oh you got
this from [__] um King from King of
Queens or or from some I'm a sitcom I
was like yeah but I'm not saying it's my
material I'm saying that I'm I'm hoping
you know about this show and we're
enjoying this joke because it's a
obvious sitcom joke right like if I did
oh my God I'm not saying I'm doing Kevin
Hart
you know yeah like you know it's Kevin
and it's a reference yeah it's a
reference we were both laughing at this
or if we do a Dave Chappelle reference
I'm not saying it's my joke we're
laughing because it's a Dave Chappelle
reference do you think that's changed
because everyone's watching different
[__] now because remember back in the
90s if you did a [__] Jim Carrey
impersonation everyone knew and you saw
it everywhere and everything if someone
was acting like the mask it was like a
no-brainer because everyone was watching
that but they announced that the options
are so thick that people think they've
got it they're like oh I got you I
copied that yeah you know it's like huh
like what the [__] like I see it so much
even in like food content right where I
see these recipes and I see them this is
my recipe and I just literally Google
those exact ingredients and it was from
somewhere online yeah it's like it's not
your recipe [__]
you [__] lied it was passed down
Generations yeah I'm like that looks
[__] Terrible by the way they're like
really that creme brulee survive the
Holocaust yeah
okay start creating this weird backstory
or they like even shame people for not
knowing something that they just found
out themselves oh God that's the worst
they're like you didn't know this
neither did you [__] yeah oh for reals
you you knew like the the [__] you knew
how this how kimchi was made yeah you
know the whole backstory behind him your
parents sat you down and told you about
the backstory about this Korean Dynasty
shut the [__] up I love those moments
though there's those are so [__]
funny when people do that when they go
like wait you never heard that wait hold
on how how have you never heard of it
like you're really gonna make a big deal
out of this thing to my manager you used
to get mad at me because I used to hate
that so much I would do that about like
rich people making me feel bad about me
not knowing rich people [__] because I'm
poor right like what's a rich people
like I know this sounds ridiculous right
but it'll be like talking about this
amazing stuff that they do that clearly
I've never done right as if I'm supposed
to really yeah yeah they'll be like oh
my gosh so I just went to
um I was just in Germany and I went to
Oktoberfest and I'd be like Oktoberfest
what's that that's like it's January and
he's like no no Oktoberfest and I'm like
never heard of it because you never
heard of Oktoberfest like no like what
do you what did they do like it's like a
festival like a German festival they
drink beer it's like beer what's that
and they're so dumb they're like you
don't know what beer is I was like bro
I've never had beer before what is that
it's like that's a rich alcohol I was
like no alcohol is where you could clean
a wound that is I should probably like
dude is this guy [__] real yeah is he
[__] real or not I was like okay let
me explain to you all right like beers
like you drink it and you have a really
[__] good time and they're like
explaining this to me and I'm like
patronizing them to death you know and I
could literally hear from my managers
like stop and I'm like no I'm gonna keep
doing it right because he's not going to
get it because he's that [__]
arrogant he goes you don't know what
[__] it out okay so like you know you
could drink it too I was like but if you
drink it you're gonna die it's like no
the percentage of beer like you could
have like 10 alcohol and I was like
but is it to sanitize your insides I'll
just keep going what what do you what
would you prefer that somebody
talk to you as if you didn't know about
something that was like above or that
when people tell you something like oh
you know Asians get surgeries to like
make their eyes look bigger like
something that you [__] know you know
what I mean I'm not sure if you've had
this right like you know when I started
going into like all these like industry
meetings they'll be like oh oh my God so
I just had a meeting with [__] John
Horowitz and I'm like how the [__] yeah
am I supposed to know who John Horowitz
is and I'll ask who's John Hoy you don't
know who John Horowitz is he just did
this black and white film that went into
[__] Sun that's 30 years ago
[__] you [__] you [__] how
you're gonna make me feel bad for not
knowing this guy who created a film 30
years ago right how am I supposed to
know this yeah and they made me look
like I'm the dumbest person ever and so
I would start saying things that they
wouldn't know about I was like dude man
like I was like sanchai is amazing like
who's sanchai he's like you don't know
the best Muay Thai kickboxer of all time
you know [__] idiot over here that's
so funny to forcibly change
sanchai is amazing yeah and then once
again my manager's [__] mad dog me
like stop do you still have that same
manager oh yeah oh good he's fed up with
me
he like a lot of people get mad at me
because they don't understand that I
kind of you know walk to the Beat of My
Own Drum yeah and so one of the things
that I I think kind of gets under my
skin that people don't understand about
me is they go
you are you self-sabotage yourself like
you could do so many great things yeah
I'm like no you think I could do great
things on things that you think is
important to me yeah right right if
that's a different thing acting is not
important to me you can't tell me I'm
going to be a great actor I know I could
be
if I dedicated my life to it and I
worked hard I know I could be but I
don't want it so what what does that
mean to me yeah I mean so that idea that
some people want things from me that I
don't want sometimes it's over my skin
well that's hard too for an agent
because that's their whole job is to get
you to want it more yeah and that's like
well then stop sending me to these
[__] auditions I don't care about
dude one of the funniest auditions that
I got to by the way I still have it
somewhere maybe I'll post it if I can
find it you have the footage of you
audition like shapes yeah yeah this is
what self tapes weren't mandatory but I
was allowed to self tape a lot because I
was doing so many of them just gone yeah
so it was for me playing um uh a Teen
Wolf
it was for like a Teen Wolf spit off of
some sort oh okay played like this Asian
wolf right okay and I remember like
looking at my agent at the time and I
submitted this thing I was like hey what
the [__] man
the role literally says handsome
fit and Young
the only thing I [__] survived like I
don't it doesn't make sense at all I was
like what am I a [__] Burmese
mountain dog am I a Chow Chow
like
I'm like I used to get so mad at this
guy I said that and I guarantee you they
were laughing at me oh No like is this
serious what if they just needed
representation for all dogs bro it was
like a small wolves
it was a script for this moment where
I'm literally like having like a
flirting moment with like a young hot
girl and bro this is the during the time
it was just after Google I was like 270
pounds terrible acne and I'm like bro
I'm not getting this role
they don't even it's funny because he
said like oh this casting director like
I just needed to see you I was like I
just had lunch with them yesterday
why are you sending me for this role I
remember I taught that casting director
I was like how hard did you laugh at my
audition and like
we didn't laugh I was like you [__]
laugh don't lie because I was laughing
right they had to have laughed you have
to laughing people laugh at good
auditions yeah I was like how often do
you get this stupid auditions like this
like honestly a lot I was like you don't
want to see this right they're like no
we don't I was like they just be
throwing everything they're just like
Taking Chances on anything so I told
them what I wanted I was like I want
theatrical film only right yeah and then
it's like this is what I want and like
send me a role that I need and like no
we're just gonna shoot you I was like
all right then we're done did you ever
get a uh audition for a role that you
thought you were [__] perfect for are
you still bombed yeah it was actually
for uh
beef
oh really it was a David chose roll
you know what's funny you told us about
that but we didn't know it was beef at
the time because we didn't know remember
you were like telling us that you
thought you were so good for it I
thought I was really good for it because
you didn't bombed they didn't pick you
right I mean they already knew who they
wanted and so it was one of those
situations and also too it didn't make
sense it was one of those roles where I
think okay maybe I could show them
something but maybe my audition wasn't
good but um I felt good about it because
I knew what Korean homes were like but
the way he played it and the way I
played it was actually night and day oh
okay okay yeah but they already had the
role for him so they what they'll do
with if you guys know if you guys want
to go into acting most major roles are
already booked and they just have
backups just in case and they go like oh
we had to go with somebody else yeah so
David Cho they already called him up and
like hey do you want this roll and they
already had them but they were
auditioning for a role but number one
the the role was for like a 45 50 year
old Asian dude that was in prison for x
amount of years and I obviously don't
look like I'm in my mid-40s you know so
I was like how do I make myself look
older
you know how would you have if they left
it up to you they're like come in the
studio tomorrow older I would just sit
down and make noises
let's get started
I would have really bad [__] spray
paint and squint at everything hey guys
I was like looking at my phone like this
you forgot to silence it too I would
tell them to pass me their phone but
I'll open up random apps yeah
it's just annoying everybody this guy is
on the role notes
hey let me see that photo and then I
open up the [__] notes you're hired
you [__] old ass guy that's the
oldest [__] I've ever seen in my life
dude let me see let me see that text
message real quick yeah
that's so old dude you want to know a
role that uh so I've I've done
practically zero acting but I got called
in to read for a role that was so
[__] major and out of the blue that I
could only blow it
it is it's gonna like it'll blow I don't
think I've ever told anyone this uh at
least not like on a thing but so when I
was doing so you think you could dance
some director
really thought that I I might look
really cool in this role so then they
they call me up and they're like hey
we're gonna send you a script look it
over and then your this character these
Pages come in the producers want to meet
with you and they want to see how you
are for this role and it was the [__]
lead
in Jackie Chan and Jet Li's Forbidden
Kingdom get the [__] out of here off of
zero acting
they just wanted me to try it out what
was that what was the the part that you
had to audition for what was this what
was the line a white kid who's like the
he's like the um it's I you know I never
watched the movie but like in the movie
there's like a white kid who's like the
lead-in between Jackie Chan and then
there's like a scene in the beginning
where he finds like a spear in a liquor
store I don't even know if it stayed
that way but uh they just wanted me to
do the scene where he like discovers uh
he discovers like an ancient weapon it
was it was of no like real intensity but
they just wanted to like uh to try it
out I had zero like I'm talking like no
acting whatsoever and I came in on that
[__] oh my God so you can imagine how
that went yeah dude bro there are some
auditions
um where I definitely bombed really bad
because I was just really bad at reading
scripts oh and so because everything to
me at the time was a comedy and so my
very first audition ever yeah I walked
into was it was like for an audition for
an episode of you like NCIS some [__]
like that right yeah for some reason I
read it as a comedy script and I don't
know why and then as I'm in the
auditioning room right I read the lines
I thought I killed it and they go
so that was a very interesting take can
we do that a little more grounded and a
little more serious I'm like what and I
looked at the script I'm like
I'm a forensic scientist and somebody
got murdered so a man just lost his life
uh maybe reflect that
I go into the car
and I [__] lean my car seat back and
I go
yes one of the most embarrassing moments
of my life dude and I just I was like
I'm they're never going to call me back
at least there's a clear explanation
though at least they go oh he must have
played it like a comedy yeah they were
like fairy but there's no there's no uh
reconciliation for just having a bad
attempt you know what I mean like what
if it was a comedy and you just were
terrible like that's worse I think like
the agent that I had to really didn't
um got really pissed at me because I got
callbacks a lot like when somebody first
asked they don't get callbacks for
almost every role they audition for so
I'll get called back after callback at
the Callback they're like dude you're
right there you're right there like it's
great like I I don't get people who get
callbacks like that and then after all I
was like no I'm not doing this anymore
and I just like killed them so like I
get it like I understand like they're
trying to make a book but they didn't
understand what I wanted so oh so they
were just like misusing you yeah I just
didn't care for these roles and it's
like they also don't understand like I
think a lot people don't understand a
lot of actors struggle
um but I've dipped myself into so many
other things and I was a self-made
person before acting that I you can't
dangle this thing in front of me that's
that's the part that's different I feel
like it's if you're not a part of the
hustle where you're just like starving
for the role like that's a different
thing huh because imagine like like even
dude one of the best actors that I
[__] know that is also a dancer
Lawrence cow
right you love Lawrence how [__]
amazing is [__] Lawrence dude so
[__] good and he is a dedicated
[__] we're lucky to have [__]
Lawrence cow out there I know yeah he's
a good representation
yeah and also outside of acting [__]
great guy and he's cool he's actually as
cool as he seems yeah cool as [__] dude
like I missed that fool so much man I
actually got to hit a muscle we should
all just go out and [__] yeah dude
like he's not one of those guys like you
know you see an actor and then they're
so cool on screen but then their actual
life like everyone hates them the
Lawrence is so goofy Lawrence is not
that like everyone loves that guy you
you can't meet Lawrence is so grounded
yeah just a good person that generally
loves the craft of acting and he's the
type of person that I really feel like
dog man like
I mean he's had a really good break
recently he had the CW Show with I'm
pretty sure it's going to go for another
season yeah but you know killing it dude
such a goofy [__] guy he had that um
YouTube channel with his buddy Canal
remember Canal yup because that was
hilarious too I just had lunch with him
not too long ago too yes yeah Canal's a
homie too when I was living in Irvine I
saw all those boys like every day nuts
dude yeah we're literally a degree apart
from each other yeah and they made those
basketball analysis videos
top probably top 10 YouTube videos made
of all time ever ever MC Echo square
there's a feasible what a [__] win
right for the community we're like yes
oh no he's at the table here bad dude
and it's so reflective of their actual
selves like they'd be saying [__] like
that all the time it was so [__]
stupid I remember a crying laugh I a lot
of people don't know that was Lawrence a
lot of people don't know yeah because
how how would you know yeah that [__]
was reposted without credit a million
times over all over the [__] bed I
didn't have his name on it yeah MC
equals square but derivatives
[Laughter]
Lawrence is one of the people I think of
whenever I get upset when I hear another
Asian actor say there's not enough Asian
good looking man and I'm glad to be one
of those men yeah this my buddy Lawrence
yeah you talking about my [__] friend
Lawrence yeah dude I'll [__] beat her
up yeah or you or Yoshi sidarso like I
think of them oh yeah but I'm like dude
that's handsome as [__] he's also one of
the nicest people I've ever met in my
life he is yeah he's [__] amazing
nice dude beautiful beautiful [__]
soul beautiful [__] man I knocked out
his tooth once and I was I know we he's
told the story on JK damn it he ran into
it is that your story really it's the
truth he ran into your punch so we so
you weren't punching I was listen he was
just thinking okay this sounds terrible
when you say it like that okay so we
were doing a slipping drill and so he
was supposed to slip to the opposite
side so I threw and he slipped the other
way and I knocked his tooth out oh yeah
oh that sounds interesting because I
remembered him saying something like you
just go really hard at every training
session no no no no no no no okay
because we've heard that from multiple
people okay you know what I've said this
so [__] Nick all right wait [__] that
stupid goza eared [__] all right
that little wonton eared little [__]
all right
if I've ever learned how to spark guess
who I learned it from oh it was Nick
himself right because Nick be going hard
as [__] too oh he does that too oh hell
yeah he does dude I've never wow like
Nick be going [__] a hard dog and so
I sparred just like him like he was my
coach I probably had a fight because of
him like I honestly try to imitate his
style so much right like people don't
know actually how good Nick is like I'm
not just saying Nick hates compliments
that's I hear that so much like even
from other Fighters like oh this guy's
[__] good yeah because Nick is very
cerebral he's very well let's just go
yeah Nick never likes compliments but
Nick is really really talented
especially as a [__] fighter he's
really really smart great coach great
everything yeah so like I've probably
trained in totality
um like in classes maybe less than a
year right so I just you know I just
practice by myself all the time yeah so
like when people always come up to be
like dude you're actually pretty [__]
decent like I'm surprised I'm like dude
that's all because of Nick like Nick was
a stickler for like teaching me like
really smart things heard that a lot and
I heard that his like fight IQ is like
his highest yeah anybody who trains with
Nick they never say like oh this guy
sucks they go oh dude this guy fight
like for reals like he should be
fighting yeah Nick is actually really
amazing but he hits hard too he hits
hard bro I think that's his thing where
you hit him and he goes his face changes
and this is Laura it's like different
like poofy disappears and I go all right
time's out I'm like I'm out he turns
into Akuma straight up yeah
Nick is good all around man I should
just hit him next time with him Nick
will just be like ah yeah if you get
Nick mad though Nick becomes a different
[__] person yeah I have a feeling
because I've never seen him seriously
mad ever yeah nobody has ever seen any
of us seriously mad like we don't get
mad like that that's true that's not the
form of expression I've only seen Bart
I've seen Joe actually seriously mad
before
um at somebody and it was like [__]
oh [__] when you see like serious Joe
I'm like oh dude you must have done
something really bad yeah because Joe
takes everything as a joke
so I seen Bart really pissed once right
and it actually almost made me piss
myself because like Bart you know Bart
doesn't have a middle ground Bart has
extremely happy and whatever yeah to
somebody gonna get hurt oh interesting
there's no middle ground so we it was
when barbell first opened up and the Geo
just caught her brand new car yeah and
there was this [__] annoying [__] on
the phone and he was like writing a note
on Geo's car it's directly on it with
his pen and then Bart nice as [__]
Bart's the nicest guy ever yeah he looks
you go oh excuse me sir can you um not
write on my on my wife on my girl's car
like you know it's a brand new car and
he goes shut the [__] up like that to
Bart and then I I'm not even joking I
sense like this air change it went from
Happy BART to
military Bart and I [__] went inside
as if like you know those like old
westerns yeah yeah one decided to open
the blind
and then you just see I hear Bart coin
get the [__] out of here before I
[__] murder you like like just kill
him what like just Stone Cold straight
face and the guy looks at him and he
just you can see the guys like color
change because it's not like a threat
like oh we're gonna fight it's like he's
gonna kill me yeah and the guy changed
and the guy just walked away come back
in this guy's [__] weird
thinking about it I'm like dog that was
literally the scariest thing I've ever
seen when you see somebody who is
consistently jovial yeah go from
this to I'll murder you oh my god oh
it's so hard to imagine because those
two [__] see the humor in every every
Everything
only time I've ever seen a mad and I've
never seen a man ever since then and I
never want to I never [__] want to
pee
I'm like oh this guy has seen [__] yeah
you know what I mean because people
forget they were affiliating gang
members before yeah it's easy to forget
that yeah yeah they were Affiliated gang
members yeah so their life is very they
follow a different [__] code that's
why I got so [__] freaked out when
Joe was like I'm Joe mama yeah that's
honestly why is because I've only known
his reputation as a gangster I never
knew like I would never think the same
guy was this guy that's goofing off
heartless super empathetic guy yeah you
know what I'm saying very understanding
a great listener super understanding
yeah [__] great boss this guy has
gone through so much to get to this
point from the guy I can't [__]
rock you know right sometimes I look at
him I go damn dog you don't have evolved
yeah and then there's other times where
I'm like that's the Joe I know yeah yeah
one time I remember I'll forever
remember this was like he when they were
at JK news and then we're all talking
and he goes
and we stop and we go
and he goes oh my bad dude I actually
responded to but I wrote it out in there
in the air
that was meant for you for us
I thought he was making a mental note to
himself no deals respond to us with this
note in the air and he forgot he didn't
say it out loud
bro I'm like that's that's Joe right
there
out here in Vietnam eating hooker [__]
when he told that story on the podcast
when was the first time he told that
story he I think he told JK news first
he told on he used to be on my podcast a
lot yeah yeah and then
um he was just all over the place and
the pandemic happened yeah yeah so us
doing it together didn't make any
[__] sense so I was like okay like
we're just gonna I'm just gonna do this
on my own and it wasn't enough to split
the money anyways Okay so he told the
story it was after this Vietnam trip
yeah bro I cried because I'm like the
[__] did you just say to me who the [__]
hooks up with somebody whose job is to
suck your dick and then you eat them out
I didn't even believe it until like the
third time he told me
I thought it was a bit like for two
whole time yeah oh yeah there's a bit
and then she asked him to come back for
like she didn't have to do any work and
then he tipped her amazing
it's like bro this guy is the funniest
guy I've ever seen in my life dude and
there'll be moments in JK news where Joe
will talk and say the funniest thing
ever but he doesn't know he just said
something ridiculous so he's like
laughing because he knows that he's
supposed to laugh
but doesn't know that he just made a
joke
I'm like dude you don't understand how
[__] funny you are so like me and
Steve have always said it like if you
could harness this it would be the
funniest stand-up ever dude he's so
[__] crazy man like you've you've had
years of experience with him and without
even knowing that it was him it's it's
also he's so unpredictable yes like
that's the that's I think my favorite
thing is that you if you watch like JK
and like let's say Anthony's talking so
he's right next to him so the camera's
forced to be like for him to be seen
he's just going like this
for the longest time like forever he's
just like
and then like it snaps and then he says
the craziest [__] but he probably wasn't
even thinking of that he was just like
sitting there Joe dude
okay last [__] story I swear to God
that's it still it's really hard for him
so Joe's a grown-ass man yeah this is
Geo's dad's funeral
right yeah and we're all sitting
together we're all in a suit whatever
whatnot and I just see Joe in the corner
of my during the funeral everybody's
crying like this
like a kid
that's it still I don't [__] funeral
bro and he's just stretching his shirt
and it's a child exactly and I knew
exactly how he was as a kid yeah like
staying still was impossible for oh man
yeah that's how it is for me too but
he's ten times worse than I am and he
was dying
trying to like [__] stay
I've never seen adult do that before
and of all times and places
good spot to do it out of all [__]
places dude like just watching him dude
that was so hard like there are moments
that we have definitely shared like
like you know when
Geo's father passed away yeah we didn't
tell the public at all for the longest
[__] time yeah she wasn't comfortable
with it which is great which is
something I really appreciate about Geo
like she shares when she's only
comfortable sharing with yeah everything
is for everybody
and you know she's like one of actually
the most misunderstood people on JKD
really a lot of people who hate her
don't know who she is and they don't
understand how amazing why do they even
hate her is what I don't get like what's
I think like she's just easy to [__]
pick on because she's really pretty you
know what I mean she says like whenever
she says something people like oh you
think you're so [__] cool you know
what I mean it's like dude Geo is one of
what heck I don't get it like jail is
actually one of the most down-to-earth
[__] I've ever met in my life
she has made a lot of mistakes just like
all of us have right but she's also
learned to apologize for it like she had
said sorry multiple times for things
that she's [__] up with which is
amazing you know what I mean people she
is one of the most misunderstood members
of JK dude like I love Geo as if she is
literally my own blood like yeah I could
be next to Geo sit not say anything and
be very comfortable in that style you
guys also like you and Geo look like you
have dead on the exact same level
language oh yeah 100 yeah you know what
I mean she like we call each other twin
flames because we're very very similar
in that yeah and like there's nothing
that needs to be said between us but I'm
just very comfortable with her like I
could just we used to do this thing in
JK where JK news were I would always go
outside and just need to be by myself
for a second there's a lot of energy
yeah and I would just sit in my car do
nothing and they should be out there she
would just sit next to me and do nothing
yeah and it was just very very nice yeah
early on we're like yeah you don't want
to say anything just chill
cool Echo
and then we'll go right back in and so
like for her she really does feel like a
sibling of mine like yeah like I've
known her for [__] years yeah so like
when I sometimes when people say
disparaging things about her I take it
personally because it's not about me
it's about her and stuff that's very
untruthful like it's like damn you don't
know how [__] amazing this woman is
like she is so
my first experience of knowing how
amazing she was like I tweeted that I
got into a car accident like my [__]
tire busted right I didn't know anything
about her and then she called me she
goes hey are you okay like I just saw
your Tweet like do you need like BART to
come and help you out and stuff I'm like
[__] [__] I don't I didn't know that I
was like close enough to you for you to
do that for me but we connected and we
bonded really well yeah and she's always
been that person for me so like and I'm
not saying that I haven't done weird
[__] up things too
in terms of like not being reliable but
she's always been reliable and sometimes
I'm not the most reliable person because
I have ADHD and I'm all over the [__]
place right you know what I'm saying
yeah yeah but she has always been a
staple so like
say what you want about her she's one of
my favorite [__] people on this
[__] Earth she was like the I've
always looked at her like she was kind
of the Olive Branch between like the
quest community and like the JK
Community because uh even if we would
invite uh JK or whatever to things that
we did she would always come out because
everyone's so [__] busy and it's like
totally understandable but she would
always make time to come to things like
she would come to all my birthday shits
yeah and I'm like dude aren't you busy
yeah yeah yeah yeah she would still show
up and she would hang out all the way
till the parking lot kick it's like all
the way to the end yeah Geo was just
always really really cool she she
definitely had a period in her life
where she didn't know what she was like
doing and she couldn't figure herself
out later on in life and then you know
those were times for her that were
really tough and she doesn't openly talk
about that stuff either while we're off
again the details about that stuff yeah
but during even those times she was very
like supportive of me and you know gave
me advice and was very loving towards me
even when she was going through hard
things so like like those are the things
that people will never understand yeah
like you have to understand like in
order for people to have a friendship
for [__] over a decade there has to
be something good about these people
right like unless all of us are evil
people but even even people don't stick
together yeah right right evil people
are alone they are by themselves at all
and they're constantly trying to usurp
each other and that's not happening
exactly and I remember even tearing up
watching them first buy their first
house together like watching them get
that house it would made me [__] tear
up because it was just very beautiful to
watch right and so and now they're eight
houses in I know it's still tearful
they've had [__] 14 forever homes
and every time I tear up yeah it's like
this is my forever home hey guys I'm
selling my forever home
foreign
but it's only for a profit of millions
yeah Millions dude and they've made
great [__] moves dude and I love them
dude like that's when you know you're in
a part of a good group when you see
somebody just do really well and then it
makes you happy to see them be very
successful you know what's so dope about
them too is they're always trying to
share everything they discover that
helps them like Bart's always telling
all of us like yo I did this thing do it
it got this good like it did this and
they're always sharing it they're not
like shiesty about like oh we figured
this financial trick out yeah pay me for
it dude whenever I need help with like
my clothing brand or it's like some
other advice he's always say hey dude
always like you should do this this and
that and he's helped a lot like when
secret society was struggling I brought
a lot of his like marketing genius over
to what we did and it helped out the
brand a lot dude he's like the guy who
really believes everybody can eat at the
table yeah yeah yeah yeah you know it
really is like too good to be true like
you don't think people are actually like
that and you think it's kind of more of
a
it's not a real thing yeah but that is
who he is yeah go2 has always told me
like hey if you need help like if I told
it was like Hey like I haven't recorded
podcasts like can you come and shoot
like four episodes with me I guarantee
you like she goes okay in two weeks I'll
I'll be available Bart will be here
she'll heal her kill taika and then I
can shoot that for you in a day and I
can fly out that's how down she is right
I will never have her do that but I'm
pretty sure I can do it like she's even
like every time I show up like oh [__] I
forgot to do a podcast she goes hey
let's go shoot one right now let's do
one together I'm like damn that's so
nice you know I don't want you to like
I'll figure it out but dude this [__]
yeah it's nice to know that that's how
down it is yeah yeah she's she is pretty
[__] amazing dude Did we tell you
about what happened when like when
Bart's dad had passed so like his um so
his dad passed away and we didn't know
and he still came in and shot JK crazy
and just didn't say anything and then
um he came in on day one of shooting
back then we were doing three days in a
row he came out on day one of shooting
his dad had already passed and and he
just stuck it out and didn't tell us
until after the third day damn and he
and he didn't miss a beat he didn't seem
like sad Bart has learned to like get in
touch with his emotions only recently so
he was actually really bad with one of
the things that Bart told me that I
didn't know he was like dude you know
like you're the you were the guy in JK
that got us to hug each other
because I'm a church boy I hug everybody
I still get my mom kisses and [__] so
they weren't doing that they were really
hugging each other and I started [__]
hugging the [__] out of everybody and I
didn't know it was like a thing he was
like Geo said that too I think she said
to me in passing from what I remember
she goes you're the one that got
everybody to hug each other because you
kept hugging everybody interesting yeah
yeah I was like yeah like nobody [__]
hugged each other like you hug everybody
and I'm like that's true I do but that's
how I grew up yeah it's the turn to your
neighbor hug your neighbor yeah like hey
guys look at the person next to you and
hug them welcome the new people yes it's
like I hate you but you didn't touch the
[__] out of them immediately yeah yeah
exactly so like they uh this is [__]
funny by the way
um so Geo
you know helps Bart a lot with his
emotions a lot and then Gio was like
telling him like Hey you need to tell
like your closest friends about this
because you need somebody to bounce this
off of so he tells Joe first and then he
tells me next
I think he told you guys after yeah yeah
Bart is a comic first always yeah of
course right and I was like hey man like
first of all I got hella mad at him
because I was like
he messaged me he goes hey David like
something big happened I need to tell
you about this I was like I was like hey
dude what's going on he goes I'll tell
you later I'm like [__] you you [__]
[__] whole day I'm in Hawaii trying to
open this oh you really did tell you
like that like that and it was on my
mind
just took up all that real estate dog it
was like fine like 8 P.M or something I
was like hey are you going to call me
right he goes oh yeah yeah I'll call you
and then he finally tells me what I was
like this is the craziest thing I've
ever heard of my life yeah and this will
start because dude my mom told me that
um
like hey like do you think your dad
killed himself because of me and I sold
I told her no it's like of course not
but in my mind I was like probably
you're annoying as [__]
that's cool
busting jokes yeah even then you know
what I mean and he was like processing
the whole thing and um like yeah he's
one thing that Barton Geo are very good
about is that when they go through their
own personal problems they're very good
at not putting that on other people
a lot of people don't do that and I've
been around people who whenever they go
they dump it all on us we're there
[__] emotional tampons
he wrote they take and take and take and
then it's still not enough that's what I
heard that like Barton Geo if they were
arguing before JK they would just go
outside and deal with it and then you
wanna hear some other funny stories yeah
we're in Hawaii
these fools
they were fighting he only told me about
this after because they went into the
room together I thought they were like
you know making out or whatever whatnot
well they were fighting but they were
whisper yelling at each other so and
then like
he told me they were telling the story I
was crying laughing he goes yeah you
know like we were actually fighting that
day too I was like I didn't hear you I
said yeah because I was [__] whisper
yelling at this [__] so like he said
that they were across at each other from
the like the queen size bed going like
I
I hate you
hate you [__] rope if you want to
leave this [__] room [__] leave
this room right now don't you
[__] doing this for like he's not
even making the house I thought they
were having a good old time they were
whisper yelling at each other dog
they're so [__] hilarious man dude I
feel bad because when he didn't uh when
we didn't know right and we're doing
these episodes we made a lot of [__]
up jokes about
[__] that would have probably triggered
it for him you know what I mean 100 but
we didn't know we were just [__]
joking and [__] and like and then as
soon as he told us that all of us like
looked back and we were like we made so
many [__] death jokes and we're
making him participate in it dude Bart
the funny thing is is like Bart probably
made more jokes in his head than you
guys did
yeah dude he copes with things
differently I mean he coped with the
grief later on yeah right because he's
compartmentalizing yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and you know he openly talked about
it on his podcast like um how he kind of
dealt with that grief and trying to
figure out what's going on yeah but I'd
be making [__] like suicide jokes all
the time
I mean I love that he's he's down to
joke about it because I think I would
want to heal that same way like I
wouldn't want people to crowd around me
all sad like I would want that same
exact treatment just did one recently
because Father's Day and he was like hey
man you want to come to my house this
weekend because I was like so pissed
because like Vegas was so it was sunny
but it was gloomy here yeah you should
come this weekend I was like I can't his
father said he goes oh I said my [__] I
said that's right I don't want to
celebrate that because my dad killed
himself
dude yeah he's just stupid dude it's so
great though like what a great way to
heal though yeah like to have that humor
and have everybody around that
understands that best quality about him
too like he knows that he's [__]
flawed and so when he makes a mistake
and he truly knows that he makes a
mistake he doesn't make excuses for it
he actually just apologizes so sometimes
the things that people would hold
against him is like I can't believe Bart
said that [__] up thing I was like but
did you talk to him
um because if you explain it to him he
would like try to break it down but if
you get through to him he'll never do it
again hmm But he has messed up stuff
where I've had to talk to him that's
happened with you like you've had to be
like hey that was messed up well not to
get into too many details but it was
like personally to me but you know they
have they've had me talk to him because
he's a close friend of mine and they'll
be like hey like this is what it is oh
okay you said this thing you should
probably go and apologize and then he'll
be like oh I got it never does it again
yeah yeah I could see him you know what
I'm saying yeah so that's a really great
quality about it once you get through to
him he goes oh I get it some people
would just get frustrated and they can't
communicate very well yeah and they
would walk away feeling like he's the
biggest [__] but I'm like Bart's a
very black and white person
so talk to him and don't get mad and
walk away say to him like Hey like I
know this is how I feel blah blah blah
and be able to have that conversation
with them yeah and then he'll get it I
feel like that's that's almost Justified
to assume that because most people
wouldn't react that way yeah like most
people are prone to just try to make
excuses or rationalize why they said
this and it becomes a long drawn out
thing that maybe not everyone wants to
deal with at that moment exactly and
Bart's not like that but Bart's actually
very easy to understand but because he's
black and white sometimes he's very well
misunderstood oh so but once again like
his greatest qualities always outshine
like his small bad qualities hmm you
know what I'm saying I think I've yet to
like see anything like that happen and
you probably won't like he's he's very
good at separating his his life like
that right and he's also like I said I
hate
sometimes people would never give them
the grace I respected a for a long time
now that they don't speak on what
happened and then even when I hear
little tidbits and I'm always like yo
why don't you guys want to just Square
it off and just because then I always
felt like if everybody knew what they
knew it would be easily understandable
and then there wouldn't be any like
negativity but
they have the high road you know yeah
and also too like
I you just want people to be happy
because happy people don't hurt people
yeah so
yeah we we want everybody to be
successful any person who used to be a
part of it outside of the drama or
anybody else yeah you always want them
to be successful because if they're not
they end up bitter yeah even though it
may not seem like it I joke around a lot
about things I'm like [__] these people
no I actually want them to be successful
I think that's what's funny is that most
people wouldn't expect it to be such a
mature point of view from like guys that
are so goofy yeah yeah yeah you wouldn't
expect them to be because I didn't at
all and and hearing it from them and
they just they're just such well-wishers
to everybody yeah I'm just like damn
that's that's usually you expect when
you're behind the scenes finally that
you get to hear the real [__] yeah but
how anticlimactic is it that the real
[__] is so nice yeah it's like what I
thought after knowing you guys for so
long I would hear the real thing and it
is just that simple yeah and in that
situation too people also have to
understand this is also a company and
there's a lot of people who quit and
leave sure yeah right it's like it's
also just a regular job as well yeah you
know so people will leave and they'll
move on and they'll do great things yeah
and they'll do great things without the
company I still think that you guys did
an amazing job navigating through a
fledgling industry like it wasn't like
there was a blueprint to follow it's
like you guys were just trying things
and the fact that it still exists today
nothing exists today from back then dude
they don't everything is [__] gone
yeah like nobody has stuck around and
we're still here we may not get the most
views ever we might be struggling a
little bit but that's also due in part
to there's so many places to pay
attention to like the Market's huge now
the market has been saturated but we
still love what we do and we still
continue to do what we do and that's why
when we come to work or quote we call
work it's all [__] fun and love dude
yeah we get to joke around we get the
same thing in things in open space and
make mistakes and not be judged yeah I
[__] love that there will never ever
be another workplace like this ever yeah
yeah yeah yeah ever no you know what I'm
saying yeah or you could even say your
gripes and they'll listen and you're not
going to get fired and they're not
trying to figure out a way to [__]
put you out of a job they'll just be
like okay cool we discussed it let's
move on from this type of [__] right you
know what I'm saying so like
like shout outs to them I know like half
this podcast is dedicating to talking
about how great these guys are but they
never talk about it they'll never
mention it I mean why would they they're
not see Malu
well guys that wraps up this episode of
The Genius parade podcast I know I would
have made any more seamu jokes but it's
so funny
shout outs to simu man I love your fat
head
um
I love it dude you're the best actor
I've ever seen in my life uh do you
always end every episode with a praise
to see who I I have to because people
think I hate him dude okay I love him
dude
I [__] love him bro
that part in the movie where you were
like hiya that part favorite dog yeah
okay yeah shout outs to semen Lube man
it's my favorite thing I use before sex
um genius played every Sundays at 12 p.m
you could obviously find Ryan on
Instagram and at jknews you got it by
the way if you're looking to book a
studio for some creative art space you
have to hit up Ryan's stuff I don't I
sold them both okay hey by the way [__]
that they're still both of them they're
great owners oh never mind he's a great
company you're killing me right now man
yeah did you start something new though
yeah yeah I do we just do set design now
for different projects that way you guys
are looking for [__] set design thank
you hit them up amazing work I actually
thought that that's what it was I
thought it was a different arm of that
oh yeah it kind of is yeah uh but you
sold that rather than rather than work
out of like make one space and just
existed there we just want to make
spaces and then leave the space it's
yours now damn
next time you come out we'll talk about
that stuff because I want to talk about
that oh yeah because like the creative
part of that's [__] amazing yeah
because I can't do that so when I see
you guys create a space Oh yeah I'm like
how the [__] did you think of that [__]
you know I mean it's pretty [__]
amazing but thanks man yeah um check out
all of Ryan's businesses remember jknews
and also check out Ryan at uh Ry anime
yeah on Instagram it's my anagram on
Instagram someone took randomly did they
yeah and they've held on to it ever
since you [__] I know whoever you are
[__] bummer like Dave is the worst plug
he's literally gotten every piece of
information
people remember it better when there's a
discrepancy in the info exactly
right out of ground all right check that
[__] out genius at 12 pm we'll see you
all next time peace thank you